we have an important preface an
important caveat an important disclaimer
before we get started and here it is
provided from my lovely lawyers here we
go i am not an investment advisor all
opinions are mine alone there are risks
involved in placing any investment in
securities or in bitcoin or in
cryptocurrencies or in anything none of
the information presented today or
really anytime since you might be
listening to this anytime is intended to
form the basis for any offer or
recommendation or have any regard to the
investment objectives financial
situation or needs of any specific
person that includes you my dear
listener so everything you're going to
hear is for informational entertainment
purposes only and with that said please
enjoy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
lemurs and squirrels how goes it i hope
you are all well this is tim ferriss
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show my guests today are naval
ravicon and chris dixon naval ravikant
is one of the most popular guests on
this podcast and for good reason
you can find my first episode with him
at team.blog naval n-a-v-a-l it was
nominated for podcast of the year when
it first came out but let's get to the
bio naval at naval on twitter is the
co-founder and chairman of angellist he
is an angel investor and has invested
more than 100 companies including many
mega successes such as twitter uber
notion open door postmates and wish many
many more you can subscribe to naval his
podcast on wealth and happiness on apple
podcast spotify overcast wherever you
get your podcasts you can also find his
blog at nav.al
and i will leave naval's intro at that
we have done quite a few interviews
together in the past with nick zabo and
also with ethereum creator vitalik
buterin
chris dixon on twitter at c dixon is a
general partner at andreessen horowitz
where for the past six years he has been
an active seed and venture stage
investor previously chris co-founded and
served as the ceo of two startups site
advisor and hunch site advisor was an
internet security company that warned
web users of security threats the
company was acquired by mcafee in 2006.
hunch was a recommendation technology
company that was acquired by ebay in
2011. chris has been a prolific seed
investor and that is the right adjective
prolific seed investor co-founding
founder collective a seed venture fund
and making a number of personal angel
investments in various technology
companies
chris started programming as a kid and
was a professional programmer after
college at the high speed options
trading firm arbitrate he has a ba and
m.a in philosophy from columbia and an
mba from harvard he's written about his
theories and experiences as an
entrepreneur and investor on medium and
before that at
cdixon.org many of his predictions have
come true a lot of what he's written
about has ended up being prescient and
we will dig into that his a16z
that is andreas and horowitz with the
number of letters between the first and
last a16z podcast appearances can be
found at a16z.com
author chris hyphen dixon and once again
you can find him on twitter at c dixon
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns and
they're worth their weight in gold i've
been using them every single day whether
you're an elite athlete or just a
regular person trying to get through
your day muscle pain and muscle tension
are real things that's why i use the
theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest muscle tension so for
instance at night i might use it on the
bottom of my feet it's helped with my
plantar fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact as massage
reinvented on some level helps with
performance helps with recovery helps
with just getting your back to feel
better before bed after you've been
sitting for way too many hours i love
this thing
and the all new gen 4 theragun has a
proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet it's easy to use and
about as quiet as an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's signature power
amplitude and effectiveness to believe
it it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so i encourage you
to check it out try theragun that's
thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragon with an oled
screen that's oled for those wondering
that's organic light emitting diode
screen personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power and the gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments on that so try theragun for
30 days starting at only 199 dollars go
to thirdbody.com
tim right now and get your gen 4
theragun today one more time that's
thirdbody.com
tim t-h-e-r-a-b-o-d
dot com
tim
this episode is brought to you by tonal
imagine having an entire gym's worth of
equipment in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv something that could fit
potentially even in a closet
fits in my closet by eliminating
traditional weights tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance with a sleek
design that can fit nearly anywhere it's
like having an entire gym and personal
trainer right in your home tonal's
patented digital weight system senses
your strength and adjusts the weight
automatically in real time so you can
get the most out of every workout i have
a number of friends including
competitive athletes who have doubled
their strength in short order in a lot
of exercises and part of the reason
that's possible is it uses a
revolutionary system of dynamic
resistance powered by electric motors
for strength you can feel you can also
do things like eccentrics
over time tonal learns from your body
and automatically increases the weight
exactly when you can handle it tonal
also uses 17 sensors to provide
real-time feedback on your form and
technique allowing you to get the most
effective workout every time it's a
strength training machine with
adjustable arms that provides more than
170 exercises for a full body workout
and that can include squats deadlifts
bench presses overhead pulls bicep curls
and more so check it out try tonal the
smartest home gym for 30 days in your
home tonal is so confident that you'll
love it they offer a full money back
guarantee you can now get tonal from 63
dollars per month at zero percent
interest over 48 months
visit www www.tonal that's t-o-n-a-l dot
com and for a limited time get 100 off
when you use promo code tim 100 at
checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim 100
tim100
tonal be your strongest
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
now we're
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and personality
chris and neval
welcome to the show and chris we're
going to start with you
and then
i figured we could begin with something
perhaps that most people would consider
non-technical and that is philosophy so
i would like to hear
first if you could explain why the
interest in philosophy and then i would
love for you to tie in
your
conversations or specific conversations
involving advice with daniel dennett and
maybe
give some context for who that is
so back in college i i sort of
introduced in computers my whole life
and i read this book gerda escherbach
which was sort of mind-blowing book at
the time and it's all about kind of the
connection between computer science and
music and philosophy and things like
this
and so when i got to college i said you
know i started taking some philosophy
classes and really kind of went down
this rabbit hole of philosophy and
actually was at one point in a phd
program
until i dropped out i was very
interested in what's known as analytic
philosophy so
language mind logic the foundations of
mathematics it's still an area i'm
interested in sort of the history of
ideas i'd say the history of science the
history of mathematics how it happens i
by no means consider myself a philosophy
expert and i haven't read that much over
the years but i have for example a
couple years ago i went and did this
whole really big deep dive into the
history of logic and computer science
and actually end up writing this article
for the atlantic about it and kind of my
argument was which is still kind of my
main area of interest is this idea that
you could have a group of people
working on something there was this
great quote i started the essay with it
was this computer scientist who said if
you went in 1905 and tried to find the
least practical area of philosophy or
any academic field you could it would be
this set of logicians like bertrand
russell and kirk gerdell and a bunch of
other people like that who were doing
these really really esoteric logical
things but it turned out that was
literally the direct lineage into alan
turing and von neumann and all the great
papers that came out in the 30s and then
that culminated in world war ii so
literally the history of computing came
from this kind of crazy group of like 10
people in 1905 and so it was that kind
of stuff that i was into reading about
that kind of stuff and the fun thing
with philosophy is you can say hey this
semester i'm going to do science and
this semester i'm going to do math so
it's really just a little bit
dilettantish or something like it's just
sort of a fun excuse to go read a lot of
smart people but yeah and then at one
point this is a guy named daniel dennan
who's sort of one of my heroes who's
written a lot of great philosophy books
kind of popular philosophy books i
highly recommend
and i had the opportunity to talk to him
and that was the point which i was
thinking about quitting and doing what i
do now basically startups
and he said to me he said look if you
think you're going to be like a great
philosopher and that's all you can ever
do you should do it otherwise i would
quit immediately
and go do something else
i just knew like i was going to be a
mediocre philosopher working on
footnotes but basically in these kinds
of academic fields there's like five
people that matter every century and
then everyone else is sort of doing you
know footnote cleanup
the other thing me and my friends had
this idea that we looked the best
philosophy paper at the end of the phd
right dissertation we came to the
conclusion that the best dissertation
would be two pages long and have no
footnotes and that was just completely
unacceptable and modern academia so
we're like there's no way that we can do
actually consider to be a great because
you know truly great philosophy just a
brand new idea a brand new set of ideas
not that i had of them i'm not claiming
i was a great philosopher but if the
goal was fundamentally inconsistent with
the nature of the program it was
probably not as practical for me i don't
want to say i'm going to push back a
little bit but interest in philosophy
deep interest in philosophy and it could
be coincidental seems to be a pattern
across quite a few currently adept
entrepreneurs and investors in the tech
space reid hoffman comes to mind i mean
obviously naval is a deep
reader and considerer of different
philosophies and just to build on your
dissertation comment
and we we don't have to spend a whole
lot of time here because i still want to
do a little bit of background
but for those who don't have firsthand
exposure to satoshi nakamoto's white
paper how long is that
it's like seven pages i think i have it
on my wall actually in my other office i
have it on the wall and it literally
fits on the poster so i believe the pdf
you know depends on the format you can
get them in like printed bible like
formats or you can get them
tedious i think the pdf seven pages you
know it's very short it's very short and
actually
probably two-thirds of it is
implementation details the core ideas
are probably
a couple of pages
similar to the bible there was a whole
long period of forum posts and other
kinds of things fleshing it out and then
the actual code the concept of the
blockchain is i think one of the
beautiful computing primitives that a
lot of those beautiful simple things is
relatively simple at his core
i'd like to revisit the logicians for a
second so burton russell and these
others
so they were the significance of that
was
largely missed at the time i mean of
course it was hindsight 2020
but i'd like to maybe use that as a
segue to something you wrote in 2013
in a blog post titled i think this is
the title of the blog post what the
smartest people do might just be a quote
from the blog post what the smartest
people do on the weekend is what
everyone else will do during the week
and 10 years
and among the tech hobbies with momentum
you included quote math-based currencies
like bitcoin end quote that's 2013. so
i'd like to ask two questions number one
is
and there were other examples that
seemed now to be quite prescient
how did you identify math-based
currencies like bitcoin to fit into the
category of what smart people are doing
on the weekend and then are there any
current hobbies that you're watching
with interest
this goes back to the lore of silicon
valley of the hackers in the garage and
steve jobs and wozniak going to the
homebrew computer club it was like this
fringe cultish club at the time in the
era of mainframe computers and things
it basically came back to this idea that
maybe that's not a coincidence that just
keeps happening that it's these things
people are doing on the weekend and
particularly they're smart people you go
and you talk to them they had a good
reason they really understood what a
personal computer could be they had very
deep thinking
so by the way a lot of this involves
actually going and speaking to people
and not trusting secondary sources i
really believe very very strongly
that one of the most important things
here you can do is just go speak to a
lot of people that's where i get all of
my information talking to entrepreneurs
talking to people that are smarter than
me
why was personal computing happening at
the homebrew computer club and not at
let's say ibm at the time once a company
gets to a certain scale it's managed by
business people and business people plan
on a one to three year horizon they're
very good at execution but typically
it's extrapolation execution like we
have this computer here let's make a
better the next version of it or
something like that
and they're not this is sort of clay
christensen's idea the idea of
disruptive innovation is that these
things come from below they look like
toys it's another kind of common theme
they come from below they look silly the
serious people poopoo it it's not a
serious thing
some of those things by the way that
people are into the obvious things to
just stay hobbies a lot of it depends on
the nature of the specific topic and is
it going to follow some kind of
exponential improvement curve and things
like that because the pc of course was
riding moore's law and a bunch of other
important trends in a way that other
fringe hobbies at the time weren't
so i've always found this to be
a small group of very smart cultish
people to be very very interesting
pattern and one thing i do a lot of i've
read a lot of history books particularly
history of innovation and this pattern
happens over and over so i'll give you
an example another example i like to use
is university of utah in the 1970s every
single computer graphics thing today
apple pixar atari the best venture
capital strategy in the 1970s would be
take a big bag of money and hand it out
at the university of utah okay because
they were all the entire future of
computer graphics was the university of
utah why because some i forgot the
specific some donor
liked computer graphics and gave money
and they're all there i always think
about it like i do venture capital i can
sit there analyze metrics and do all
this other stuff or i can just go try to
find university of utah that's what i
think about all the time like where is
that and by the way a lot of it now is
on the internet it's in the discord it's
in a reddit
a lot of what i did in that list i had
in 2013 a lot of that came from reddit
it's what is the current definition of
the frontier and there was a time when
it was wild west there was a time when
it was conquistadors and people setting
sail in the age of sale and today it
feels like the frontier is on the
internet and even on the internet the
frontiers within web3 and crypto because
it's sort of the least regulated the
most decentralized the most
permissionless
24 7 365 markets that are self-funding
hackers from all around the world can
participate you can be anon or
pseudoanon or just have a crypto punk is
your profile and nobody has to know who
you are all that matters is the output
of your code and if it works you can
make huge amounts of money satoshi
nakamoto may end up being the richest
person who ever lived and could have
pulled it off completely anon and that's
not the only one there are huge fortunes
being made and lost on this
decentralized anonymous frontier and now
i think
we're seeing web 3 starting to pull in
all the talent all the smartest people
in silicon valley seem to be looking
from their nine to five jobs into 24 7
web 3 and figuring out how to
participate every company that i'm
involved with that's not a web 3 company
calls me and asked me about a token or a
web3 angle and obviously some of it is
just to make money but some of it is
this this appeal of open source open
platforms portable data user privacy
user control keys and community owned
and generated networks so i want to hop
in here this is all very important and
we're going to come back to it and we're
going to get to a definition of terms
also just for people who are not
familiar with web3 before i get to that
just because i want to try to create a
thread going from 2013
in that blog post to here
university of utah how did you find this
particular university of utah math based
currencies like bitcoin in 2003 or pro
or just prior to that and then we're
going to bring that into
web 3.
like a lot of these things it started
with i think friends naval could have
been part of that fred wilson their sort
of early group of people that were kind
of getting interested in bitcoin
i used to be technical i'm not
particularly technical now but i went
and kind of used bitcoin and i was
particularly interested in the
programming language around it which i
can talk more about now we have
platforms like ethereum with much more
robust programming abilities so you know
i went kind of used it and the idea i
have to say it appealed to me initially
i had come from actually the first
thought actually because you use this
thing called hashcash so hashcash is the
algorithm it's used for bitcoin mining
what's called mining which is a way to
incentivize the people to run their
computer and run part of the bitcoin
network i started a computer security
company in 2004 and it actually looked
at using hashcash so hashcash had been
talked about for a long time as a way to
fight internet spam
i mean this is what i was working on the
idea was why do you have spam it's a
tragedy the commons problem where
because it costs zero to send an email
if you can make 100
every million emails spammers will just
do that
and so one idea that went back
really back to the i think the 90s was
idea of charging somebody a little bit
to send an email but then how do you do
that when you don't have native internet
money so the idea was you force them to
do with computation and i actually had
looked at commercializing this at one
point i didn't do it
but it couldn't figure out the whole
thing when i first saw bitcoin i'm like
oh it's stored hash cash adam smith
called capital is stored labor
and so that's what bitcoin actually from
my vantage point back then it was like
oh wow it's hash cash but it's stored
and that was actually what got me
initially interested in then i started
going down the rabbit hole as we say
you'll hear this phrase a lot from
crypto people because it's very much
this looking glass experience where the
outside narrative is just so incredibly
not accurate about web3 and once you go
and learn it yourself i get an email now
i'll probably get this too every day now
from a web 2 person a good entrepreneur
saying oh my god
i didn't understand what this was and
now that i do it's like completely
changed my life it's a transformative
thing when you go down that rabbit hole
so i kind of went down that rabbit hole
although there wasn't this deeper rabbit
hole back then but i think probably i'm
guessing that paul had a similar
experience i read about the byzantine
generals problem and the solution to
that in order as well you can now
organize people without rulers could you
explain what that is naval yeah
byzantine's general's problem is a
problem that basically says how do you
get people to coordinate when nobody
knows each other nobody trusts each
other and by using proof of work aka
you can say well i've done the work to
have a credible vote and so anybody who
hasn't done the work hasn't done the
vote and so now you can take systems
that before would have to be run by
centralized authorities ranging from the
government running money to mark
zuckerberg running facebook and you can
replace them by a credible vote of all
the people participating in the network
and you know they're not cheaters that
they get to have a say because they've
done the work and one way to do the work
is hash cash but that's essentially what
blockchains and web3 do
web 3 basically says okay we can now run
this network through the people who have
invested into the network and they can
invest with money they can invest with
resources or they can invest proof of
work which is sort of the most robust
way to do it while keeping it
decentralized but i think this may lead
us into
we're probably getting to the point
where we should define what we mean by
web 3. uh and i think
chris has articulated one of the better
definitions out there one of the best
definitions and perhaps chris we could
also start
just to show i don't it could be change
it could be evolution but you know web
one web two web three if you could lay
it out
so the way i think about it is web one
the internet of course existed before
the 90s but the web sort of this killer
app on top of the internet was created
in 1990 and so i sort of think of web
one is let's call it 1990 to 2005. the
key thing with web one is it was
dominated by open protocol so the web
has a protocol called http email has a
protocol called smtp these were the
platforms you were building on then so
if you were larry and sergey and you
were building google you were building
it on top of http on top of the web and
the web was open which means no one
controlled it what that means from larry
and sergey's point of view is they knew
if they built a successful product a
successful search engine they would own
it and they would control it and you
couldn't have somebody come along and
say i'm going to take 50 percent or i'm
going to shut you down it's the web it
was open and similar to let's say in
economics if you talk to an entrepreneur
or an investor they'll say they like to
invest in countries with predictable
rule of law they don't like countries
where the government seizes the assets
and things like this the same thing
happens with startups and entrepreneurs
they want to build on a platform that
they know they can trust and so that was
what was so great about that first year
of the web and why you had so much
incredible innovation and investment and
it was i think most people would agree
today that was sort of a golden period
of innovation
but the products were limited in the
sense that it tended to be i call it
skeuomorphic where
people were taking things from the
offline world like magazines and putting
them on the internet
if you go back and look at the 90s web
it was very much experienced like a
magazine you didn't have things like
social networks and user-generated
content to nearly the same degree that
started really kind of percolating this
year people call web 2. let's call it
around 2005.
and at that time you had sort of two
competing models like let's just take
twitter there was an open protocol
called rss that was the obvious thing to
compete with twitter i mean it's still
around but it's not nearly as popular as
twitter and facebook and everything else
so there were sort of open ways to build
social networks in the 2000s and then
there were closed ways to build them and
for a variety of reasons i won't go into
all the details the closed way is one
and a lot of it had to do with ease of
use the way i think about it is web 2
the open protocols were just limited in
what they could do so if you want to set
up a website in 2008 let's say and you
wanted to have sort of simulate the
functionality of twitter you'd have to
go get like a web hosting provider buy a
domain name and do a whole bunch of
other things
everyone tried to kind of reuse domain
names essentially domain names in the
earlier in the pre-blockchain world
they're the one thing you can really own
on the internet it's your domain name
you control it and so the open side kept
trying to kind of use the domain name
again and again but it costs eight
dollars you have to go set it up it was
very technical meanwhile you go to
twitter and it's like three clicks and
you choose your name and you're in and
your friends are there and then mobile
phones came along and the whole thing
accelerated and here we are now with
five plus companies that kind of control
the internet so web3 is coming along and
so web3 is
my definition is it's an internet owned
by users and builders orchestrated with
tokens so this new concept of a token is
kind of the key concept of web3 this
comes sort of historically
from the movement that started with
bitcoin although i think it's sort of a
different branch of the genealogy or
something and a lot of the stuff's
actually built on a different crypto
network called ethereum and then there
are other kind of alternatives to it the
big kind of innovation with ethereum was
it's fully programmable it's a computer
it's funny this is the most
controversial thing i've said on twitter
i got this huge when i said blockchains
are computer they are computers and
literally if you go look at alan
turing's on computability paper a
computer or von neumann or any of the
great computer scientists a computer
something you write code and it can
store things ethereum has almost turing
complete programming language and can
store information it's a virtual
computer a computer that runs on a
network of physical computers which is i
think what kind of trips people up but
it's a computer it's a very powerful
computer that has new properties the
prior kinds of computers didn't have and
one of the things you can do on these
you can create these things called smart
contracts which are code that will
continue to run in a certain way and you
can also create these things called
tokens and tokens can be fungible like
kind of cool cryptocurrencies are or it
can be non-fungible nfts and they can be
something like which i think some people
have heard about now which are things
that can be represented by a piece of
media for example you're buying this
collectible basketball card or this
collectible work of art things like that
why tokens are so important is they now
provide a mechanism by which value and
control can be given to users and
builders as opposed to simply to
centralize companies so you can build
today
there are two things one is remember
before i said the functionality wasn't
quite there for for the open side in web
2. it's now there you can now build
something that looks and feels like
facebook or twitter
using open protocols and using this new
kind of philosophy where the value and
control accrues to the users of the
network not to a company because there
is no company and you're going to see
more and more things products launched
like this where there is initially
there'll be some kind of r d
organization that helps create these
protocols but over time they go away in
the same way that there is no bitcoin
company
and the ethereum has a non-profit
foundation that supports r d but there
is no ethereum company and this is how
i believe
the most important internet products
will be created in the future is through
this kind of new means
and why will it be done this way one is
it's better because wouldn't it be
better if the drivers on the uber
network owned uber and got to
participate more in the value creation
and also in the control and governance
of that system i think that's clearly a
better thing for society and i also
think it's just going to be a winning
product if you look at people in these
web 3 communities no web 3 company no
crypto company has ever spent a dollar
on marketing including coinbase i was on
the board for years no marketing why
because tokens are self marketing when
somebody owns something and feels skin
in the game they want to go talk about
it they want to evangelize it i think
web3 is not only better for the world
but it's also going to beat web 2
because it's going to be more popular
because the people get really excited
when they actually get to participate
the internet is 100 the most important
invention of the century that's i don't
think that's hyperbolic to say that and
we're literally talking about how is
money and power going to flow on the
internet this is such an important issue
and yet it's caricatured in the press
and things is like tech bros money this
and that it's so misunderstood
and it's so important which is why i get
fired up about it because i feel like
if people like me and naval don't
explain this that i think it's a very
important thing i guess i'll say i'll
just if it's okay with you guys share a
little bit speak for a second and also
try to
paraphrase his muggle and then i want
you to poke holes in what i say
so first i'll say
that i'm relatively new to this fear but
like you said
once it started to land or a sink in
i felt something and this is going to
sound very
odd perhaps but this like physiological
quickening that really kept me up i was
not able to sleep well for
about a week straight
and that only happens to me every like
five to seven or five to ten years
because i started to see some of the
possibilities and some of the beneficial
societal changes and
on and on and on that
not just could are already in a sense a
byproduct
of
this paradigm shift so
tell me if this captures some of the
essence and then either of you can poke
holes in it but just to
highlight a couple things so people
might think of web one
as
read-only largely read-only
and open then we have web 2 read write
but as we've seen it it's become more
centralized with a lot of these large
companies
and you don't own like you said aside
from maybe a domain name
you are not
in control of your own destiny you have
very few
rights
your reputation is not transferable if
you are on a platform like twitter you
can be de-platformed and we put that
aside but it's it's centralized you're
at the whim of a handful of companies
which a lot of people will sign up for
like you said because of convenience
ease of use etc web 3
then appears to introduce a number of
things including
property rights and decentralization
and this is not going to be a perfect
comparison but like if people think of
say like rei and a co-op
it would differ in the sense that we're
not necessarily going to have management
per se with a truly decentralized
platform
but
what i have seen firsthand and i want to
give people a concrete example just to
point out a very
niche
group perhaps that i've seen benefit
very clearly and that has been
artists and so i want to talk about this
just for a second because i have friends
who are photographers friends who are
graphic artists friends or musicians
who were crippled financially by kovid
when they couldn't tour when they
couldn't do things because they're only
getting paid one cent per stream on some
of these music streaming services
with the ability to create
unique pieces of property
in the form of nfts
and launch projects
their futures have entirely changed and
i want to highlight something for folks
and that is it's not because of the
initial sales price the model for
authors the model for musicians
has some royalty component but you kind
of get paid up front and then you have a
pittance of some percentage that you
make on the back end
but with a smart contract like you said
if we think of ethereum as this world
computer with a smart contract instead
of a ton of middlemen
who are kind of taking the line's share
of profits you can set in advance
certain things that happen automatically
like if you are an artist
and your work is resold and then resold
again and resold again well if you're
operating in a traditional art world you
get paid once that's the end of the
story
instead of that now people are making
the lion's share of many of them
of their
income from these secondary sales and
it's all done automatically they don't
have to trust some agent or a broker or
a rep or a curator
to pay them they don't have to audit
accounting because it's all on the
blockchain so i just wanted to give
that example
and
wonder if either of you would like to
elaborate on any aspect of that correct
any aspect of that or give an example
of other things that you're seeing that
are exciting to you
yeah i would just only summarize what
you guys have said because i think
you've approached it the right way but
basically what you're saying is that
digital private keys enable digital
private property and so we finally have
private property in the internet and we
don't need
people like spotify or even the studios
and the labels to determine who owns
what private property and hold it with
their database entries and their lawyers
we can each do it ourselves we can
finally each and chris got made fun of
on twitter for this we can each own a
piece of the internet but it's
absolutely true we can create digital
scarcity and it is a very powerful thing
because then it can map to real-world
scarcity because the real world is not
completely abundant in everything the
real world does have scarce economic
resources and so we can have digital
scarcity and digital private property
and in a web 3 context there are three
critical things that both of you have
touched on but i just want to summarize
them for the listener
that really make web 3 so unique so
distinct and so revolutionary
which is in a normal model we're used to
thinking of a computer program as an
application run by a third party where
they control the code they own the data
and they own the platform and the
economic benefits and then we get our
scraps we put up tweets we put a podcast
maybe we get a few shekels from spotify
maybe we've got a few hearts on twitter
and a few retweets but it's not a lot
the owners of spotify are getting far
richer than the creators and the
podcasters on spotify and the musicians
in spotify
not to pick on spotify they're just
emblematic of the whole thing and we've
had this transition where it's like web
one okay who won that microsoft maybe
netscape and and google was a big winner
of web one and then web two who won that
well it's apple and google and maybe
facebook and is web3 also going to be
controlled by big companies no the
beauty of web3 is
for the first time
all the data is actually
open the data is literally living in the
blockchain or in distributed systems but
it's secured it's actually secured far
better than these corporations can
secure our data because it's each
secured by our own private key so each
of us has a safety deposit box now in
the cloud that we can give selective
access to with our private keys to
people who need them when they need them
and then close them off again so they're
not leaked in the next credit reporting
hack or the next big company hack and
then who owns the platform underneath as
chris said it's the contributors own the
platform instead of corporations own the
platform and all the people who are pro
co-op and who are pro-collectivism
should be embracing this because now we
can own the platforms that we are
actually building with our collective
creative efforts and finally developers
love this because the code is now open
instead of being closed so it's this
insane concept a revolutionary concept
where we've flipped applications from
being closed code corporations own the
platform and users are the data to open
code contributors own the platform and
users own their data and so now these
things become completely composable and
i think one of the reasons why the web3
revolution is going to be so non-linear
and so unexpected so fast is because
with open code means these applications
plug into each other like lego blocks
you go buy a lego for your kids well it
connects to every lego piece that your
kid already owns it connects to all the
other lego pieces of the kids down the
block and they can build anything they
want out of it and that's how code on
web3 works that's how data on web3 works
and that's how even ownership on web3
works where i can own a little piece of
every platform that i contribute to and
this is absolutely a revolution now
could you define a word which comes up a
lot in web 3 composable and what that
means how people use it
the beauty is this is all open source so
it's not even apis anymore i don't have
to access through the very limited apis
that a twitter might expose and then
take away later on as they've famously
done i can literally connect to the code
at any point that i want to and then in
open source you only solve each problem
once so if somebody has built a good
version of how to solve a certain
problem i'm just going to reuse that and
reuse it again maybe i'll fork it maybe
i'll improve it a little bit maybe i'll
port it to a slightly different system
but essentially at the fundamental level
each problem only has to be solved once
so composable means that it's like legos
or like digital legos where i can just
copy the lego and then build on top of
it so the effect to a competitor is like
a voltron type thing where all of a
sudden all the apps in web3 can sort of
team up to create any app needed example
is there was an innovation in defy
called automatic market makers which is
instead of having to have an exchange
where you have paid market makers and
firms on the other side ensuring
liquidity in any market you know you go
in the stock market you buy a stock
there's someone else on the other side
who is paid to provide liquidity to sell
you the stock at the exact moment that
you want to buy the stock but in web 3
we created this innovation with defy
actually called automated market makers
where you can just do it through code
now once you've done that in code and
most famous companies unit swap which is
of course an end recent investment so
congratulations chris but once it's done
then anybody else can copy it then it
can just be plugged in dropped into any
new application so if you look at for
example games that are going to come out
that are web 3 based they're going to
have entire market economies in them
they will have custody solutions they
will have nfts built inside of them
they'll be completely composable in that
any piece from any other app can plug
into any other app permissionlessly and
so you're building an edifice it's
almost like building a civilization or a
city of interconnected apps instead of
these silos in which the data is not
portable the code isn't portable users
aren't portable so that's probably way
longer of a definition than you wanted
and chris can give you a crisper one i'm
sure
i think that was great i think i like to
say that composability is to software as
compounding interest is to finance right
it's sort of this magical thing where if
you get it going it has a sort of
exponential hockey stick i think related
to what neval said i think one thing
people who aren't in the tech business
may underestimate is how dominant open
source software is so open source
software went from a curiosity in the
90s i happen to be watching a thing
about microsoft in like 1999 in the
antitrust case the word linux doesn't
come up it's all java of course what
actually happened is linux is the thing
that won
99.9 of the code in the world is open
source software that runs so every
server you talk to on the data center
that's almost all linux your android
phone is linux most of the software on
your iphone is open source how did open
source win it's composability this is
what neval said you only have to solve
each problem once once you solve a
problem just go on github and fork it
and reuse the code what web3 is doing is
taking that level of rapid innovation
and applying it to web services in
addition to software the one thing
software couldn't do is it couldn't run
itself it relied on a company to run it
so a lot of the tech industry today is
take open source software add a little
bit of extra proprietary software on top
and then instantiate it run it and then
charge for it it's software as a service
and that's great and they provide value
and
they should make money from that but
the kind of key thing driving underneath
is this composability of open source
software and now we're going to extend
that to this new area yeah composability
even goes beyond software even though
that's how it's commonly used it even
goes into media so for example today if
i want to build something on top of the
star wars platform i gotta go cut a deal
with disney but in the open source
composable nft world
artists are basically giving away the
concepts yes you can always right click
and save an image or the code and then
modify it but you can build on top of it
so people will be building games they'll
be building cultural artifacts new memes
new music on top of nfts and more value
accrues to the underlying nft because
that's becoming more popular at the end
of the day the value of a piece of art
or media is directly proportional to how
the community around it and who's using
it and who's promoting it and who's
working with it so it kind of blows away
this idea of copyright and intellectual
property and instead it creates the most
powerful memes in the world means the
broad sense of music in movies and books
included in memes not just little
internet memes that we are familiar with
and media itself becomes composable and
the greatest artists are going to have
the greatest distribution that's why not
to pick on our friend but you know one
reason why i think joe rogan others make
mistakes by going to spotify is that the
power of a meme the power of an idea is
determined by how many computers it's
running on the power program is how much
computation power has behind the power
of ideas how many brains is it running
in so if you have good ideas you want to
spread them as far and wide as possible
that's why i'll never charge for a piece
of content and no one their right mind
who has good ideas should you don't want
to restrict the avenues you want people
to recompose your ideas akira dawn takes
stuff that i say and remixes into music
and there's smart nonsense out there
making videos and cool animations out of
it jack butcher does visualizations that
this is all free or eric jorgensen does
the almanac i don't have to do any of it
this is all composability around media
now i don't have an underlying
monetization mechanism but if i wanted
to i could issue nfts against the
original content and there are
collectors and people who will pay for
that and my content is just becoming
more and more famous so that's an
example of composability in action that
extends beyond just software
composability is a very very powerful
concept and if you want to for example i
know a lot of your listeners create a
lot of content they're content creators
and innovators and creators themselves
and if you want your content to
get as much out there as possible don't
hold anything back if you have good
ideas you want to spread them as widely
as possible and you wish you should be
so lucky that other people come and
compose them with their own content and
create new memes and new ideas
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
you can ucan what you eat and how you
live exercise sleep stress all play an
important role in how your body handles
glucose its main form of energy you
might think of blood sugar that is
glucose when glucose levels are steady
and you avoid spikes you're improving
your metabolic fitness an important way
to take control of your metabolic
fitness is to eat and fuel with foods
that help regulate blood sugar to help
enhance my own metabolic health i was
introduced to you can by dr peter etia
who said there is no carb in the world
like it ucan's patented ingredient super
starch has the remarkable ability to
provide a steady release of energy
without spiking blood sugar levels i use
ucan's energy powders and low calorie
bars to maintain focus throughout long
days for exercise better performance
when training and to avoid fatigue
without making metabolic compromises so
when i need a scooby snack when i need a
little pick-me-up i reach for you can
ucan has a variety of different products
with super starch to help you balance
your blood sugar from energy powders and
bars to granola and almond butter
there's a whole suite check out my
favorites at
ucan.co tim that's ucan.co tim and save
30 on your first order that's ucan dot
co slash tim
i'd love to add just a couple things
here just to give some sort of spice and
specifics to some examples as you just
did
and
to
further explain why this stuff has kept
me up late at night
by the way the temperature is just going
to become a crypto podcast
no it will not it will not i promise
folks even though i'm getting pulled
into the deep water and getting spun
into the vortex i i'm able to tread
water and i will i will not pull
everyone in with me but
this stuff is important i think it's
very important to explore
and it's excited me because i have seen
how much
good creators good authors good
musicians have struggled because they
are not good at marketing
but they have die hard fans maybe a
small group of diehard fans but they
have some number of die hard fans and
many of the listeners of the podcast
will recognize
the title of an essay or blog post
called 1000 true fans by kevin kelly i
know
that
chris you've you've also written about
1000 true fans you can find it at kk.org
i recommend it consistently all the time
and what
web 3 allows you to do
is align
your interest with collective interest
with other
true fans self-interest by allowing them
to own
digital property that you create and
what has excited me
is i'm seeing a lot of experimentation
so we were talking about some of the
advantages of chris you were talking
about some of the advantages of web3 one
of the advantages of web3 is also it
appears and please correct me if i get
any of this wrong guys is that it is
very
easy relatively speaking compared to say
web 2 era
for
many companies or projects to reach
escape velocity so if they're raising
money for instance they might raise once
or twice small amounts of capital and
then they have a token
and they're able to sort of control
their destiny through a collective who
act as stakeholders and
in addition to that if we look at an
example like board api club people can
take a look
you're seeing because of the
composability right this lego block
aspect and
low barriers to entry with respect to
cost
that people are able
to experiment widely and in the case of
board api club
and thanks to
punk6529 for sharing this particular
example with me because i wasn't aware
in addition to selling say the the jpeg
associated with this nft this property
title that gives you this digital asset
commercial rights were also provided to
at least some purchasers of these board
eight yacht clubs so then you have
people who are going out with their
specific board ape
and creating
coffee companies or creating craft brew
companies
i've never seen anything like that
before and certainly if you're a young
young tech savvy intellectual property
lawyer your services are going to be in
need so good to get up to speed but
the fact that all of these experiments
can be run
concurrently at such low cost
says to me that the ecosystem is going
to produce through natural selection and
evolution and
recombination of different types lots of
things that will be very very exciting
and you know it doesn't even matter if
98 99 end up being garbage because the
winner is kind of like finding
amazon or google in 99 or 2 000
will end up being so impactful and maybe
that's just me drinking the kool-aid i
don't know but that's how it feels to me
yeah i mean like right board apes i
think that the recent drop they did with
the mutant apes so they did this thing
where you got like a potion and you
could get kind of your mutant
counterpart i think they made 100
million dollars i don't as far as i know
they haven't raised venture capital and
they made 100 million on that one drop
so certainly yes it's a different
economic model they take it farther
where you get the commercial rights the
next stage which people are playing
around with now is to actually have the
community create
narratives and so for example wattpad
you know these kind of fanfic community
imagine the next harry potter the future
harry potter is owned by the nft holders
and they get to decide they get to write
all sorts of interesting fiction and
they get to vote and decide what becomes
canon and what is not imagine the
passion people have for star wars and
all these other kinds of communities and
now imagine they own a piece of it and
they control a piece of it it's about to
get really really interesting i don't
think there's been this much creative
kind of energy since the 90s i don't
think mobile compares to it now we get
into the meat of it which are nfts
non-fungible tokens and this is
something that chris has been on from
day one of all the investors that i know
in the entire space chris has been the
first one who got into nfts in a big way
and has stayed consistent on in fact
february of this year i remember meeting
with him and all he wanted to talk about
nfts not even understand at the time and
i was like yeah whatever chris that
sounds cool nice toy and i'm like what
did you say again
so i sort of missed nfts but nfts for me
answered a whole bunch of questions that
i didn't have the answer to before one
question was
a bunch of people showed up and they
bought bitcoin early and they get to get
rich in this giant wealth transfer as we
move from fiat currencies into sort of
scarce math back currencies as chris
also once called them
and so does that just mean that the
people who showed up in 2009 to 2015 or
16 get rich and everybody else kind of
is a pauper no there's a funny quote out
there floating around where somebody
said every generation invents its own
new ponzi scheme and rejects the
previous generation's ponzi scheme
and
now we're moving in much faster times so
the previous generations ponzi scheme
might have been bitcoin or ethereum if
you think about what bitcoin is bitcoin
shows up and says we reject fiat we
reject printed money we reject kings and
rulers and tyrants we want the people's
currency great we got that and then
someone says wait you can create your
own currency well i want to create my
own currency so you get all these alt
coins and everybody steps up and says
well i got my own currency so ironically
there are now probably more currencies
out there than their tokens there are
more there's more currencies than
bitcoin and so people are fighting to
say well instead of your ledger of
record let's use my ledger of record and
nfts are people say come up and say
actually
maybe digital value digital assets are
like fashion their culture they're
always emerging they're always composing
they're always combining they're always
going out of style and just like in the
real world anything that's in fashion
can hold value it could be real estate
which is a real use case it could be oil
it could be gold it could be every
single house it could be every single
business it could be a pair of shoes it
could be a laptop for a brief period of
time the same way every digital asset
that has a community and a culture
around it can hold value for some period
of time now of course it will be very
non-linearly distributed the vast
majority of objects will trend towards
zero value it may be flashes in the pan
but at least this gives a chance for
everybody who's coming late to the
crypto revolution late in quotes because
we're still so early gets a chance to
say okay we can define any object as
having value that we believe has value
and these cultural memes that we're
creating around nfts like board 8 yacht
club they don't have to like harass you
into huddling them hodling is this meme
in the bitcoin community right you got
to hold your bitcoins a misspelling of
hold called hoddle
but in the nft world you hold for
sentimental value if you're punk 6529
someone comes up to buy your punk you're
not gonna sell it in fact i think just
famously recently one of the punks who's
using it as twitter id because it's the
new blue check mark on twitter but it's
actually validated and verified through
wallet ownership he got offered
something like 10 million dollars for
his crypto punk and it was just kind of
a random generic little eight bit pixel
crypto punk but he refused to sell
because that was his identity and he
basically had to say even though i may
not be worth that much money i'm not for
sale and that actually made it a
cultural meme and an icon and now his
crypto punk's probably worth even more
so nfts are this absolutely fascinating
rabbit hole i think chris was probably
the first investor to identify them at
scale going all the way back to his
dapper labs investment these are the
people who built crypto kitties and
evolving from there so i would just love
to hear chris go into nfts like the
evolution of them and kind of where
they're headed yeah i'm obviously i'm
very um excited about it i think that
they're like i think they're very very
broad what i would call primitive
primitive just so you understand like
the way we kind of use it is there's
these kind of key building foundational
building blocks of the internet and
i think that most of the issues that
developed were some of the things i
talked about earlier about how you could
only you were limited in what you could
build using open methods
and
a lot of the problems frankly i think
come from advertising the fact that we
didn't have native payments and tokens
and all these things we now have what
google wants to do they want to have a
digital closed loop and a digital closed
loop prior to crypto you could really
only do that with advertising and so we
built this giant infrastructure the
internet now is powered by banner ads
and
search ads and things like this and that
has been great for a few companies it's
generally been really really bad for
creative people there was someone had a
great tweet yesterday
the web two companies convinced you to
give away your creations in exchange for
little hearts but yeah tell me about how
nfts are the real scam or something it
was some
formulation like that like it's kind of
amazing that they've convinced all these
people oh you know instagram what do
they pay out zero facebook zero twitter
zero youtube 50
apple just for having the phone they
take 30
do you know how many businesses can't
survive when you take 30 percent it's
kind of crazy that we put up with this
so
now as you said put aside nfts just look
at like sub stacks so there's no crypto
and substance so what's going on with
subspec it's a platform like a sort of a
newsletter platform you can go to as a
writer and have people subscribe to it
it's relatively simple really elegant
idea but the interesting thing you see
now is you see writers who previously
might make i don't know what a hundred
thousand dollars or something getting a
million dollars a year and you see a lot
of people saying hey that shouldn't
happen we were told the internet is bad
for creative people the internet is not
bad for creative people web 2 is bad for
creative people spotify i just saw the
staff the other day spotify advertises a
stat they have 8 million artists 14 000
of them make 50 000 a year the rest make
less than that
those are businesses you have costs you
basically it's very hard to live below
that so 14 000 kind of make a living
out of 8 million is that working i'm not
blaming spotify by the way a lot of that
money goes to labels and i think
spotify's a good company
it's the model it's the logic of that
model
so and then you have these cases of like
this musician blau who i think he's like
a medium-sized artist on spotify
he did an nft drop he made 11 million
dollars
even if you assume that 11 million
dollars is a bubble or something people
say it's a bubble if he made a hundred
thousand dollars it's transformative
it's the same thing that's going on with
sub stack and so what you have is now
you have this really powerful new way
for creative people who were previously
getting banner ads at best
very poor monetization are now able to
go and and create all sorts of
interesting things and this is we're
seeing the early versions of it you
could create a jpeg you can create a
digital album art sort of an obvious
thing the musicians are doing now but it
can be much more than that it's it's
just an object just like in the real
world we have all sorts of different
classes of objects we have art we have
utilities we have nfts are just as broad
a concept and so i think you're going to
see all sorts of interesting
experimentation where you know maybe you
a musician you get you get something
that's beautiful but also you can go use
in different ways you can take it from a
game or bring it into another experience
or use it to go to a real life show as a
ticket it's also it's a means of
patronage i think one of the things i
experience i i really encourage people
to participate in these communities to
understand them i buy nfts on foundation
which is one of our investments which is
sort of a high-end art
nft platform curated platform
for example there's a science fiction
writer who i sorry graphic designer who
i bought a bunch of his nfts and he dm's
me and now we're friends
and it's like i never understood people
that gave to bot physical offline art
i've never had any interest in it now i
kind of get it though because i'm like
hey this guy's cool
i want to be part of his be in his
network i do venture capital i hang
around with tech people all day it's fun
for me to like be able to talk to an
artist and at the same time i can
support him in this sort of
non-transactional way and be his patron
and see if some people are buying stuff
on these websites to make money some are
doing it to patronize some are doing it
to i think down the road we're gonna see
more and more utility use cases the
gaming is really interesting right now
this i think the world hasn't seen this
yet but i will tell you we have a games
group at our firm that doesn't do crypto
and it's close to 100 of the things
they're seeing now these are people out
of these are founders that come out of
like riot and blizzard and things like
this i think it's close to 100 of the of
the meetings they have now involved nfts
the games people get this they're at the
cutting edge especially the kind of the
younger ones the next cohort and there
is going to be so much interesting stuff
and these things these are going to be
real utility so you can take this piece
of art you can take this sword and you
can mix and match and move it around and
they all kind of immediately get
composability and why it's important and
we're just going to see like wave after
wave of very creative things i think of
an nft as it's as general a concept as
the webpage think about the website when
it first comes out people like oh it's a
website you know and they try to kind of
map it to the offline world it's like a
brochure but then as we saw over this
sort of 30-year period all of these
clever people come and they innovated
what it's not a website it's a social
network it's a sas tool it's this it's
that nfts are going to be just as broad
it's a core new concept the idea of
owning something on the internet another
way i like to think about it is like
imagine if in the real world
we couldn't own anything and every time
you go this is kind of a wacky analogy
but like every time you go to a hotel or
a restaurant they're like you gotta
change your clothes and buy a new outfit
this is how the internet works today and
then you leave like hey you got to give
that stuff back right
and then one day somebody comes along
and they say no you can take it with you
yeah imagine the amount of innovation
that would kick off that's kind of
what's been going on on the internet we
had this sort of renting fiefdom design
and we've just kind of broken it open
and so people say oh it's a bubble
that's not i think it's the beginning of
this incredible 20-year kind of creative
run i believe i'd love chris for you to
talk a little bit more about the gaming
because i think nfts
in the gaming context are
easily understood by a lot of folks even
if they don't game but a lot of the
applications make sense to me so i mean
you could talk about anything you want
right i mean so rare is kind of
interesting but i think even more
interesting not necessarily more
interesting but there's been talk and i
think some of this might be kind of
bright-eyed bushy-tailed
idealism but the possibility of say
universal basic income
when we look at let's say something like
ygg or
could you just speak a little bit to
that and what that means because it's so
interesting to me and interesting is a
lazy adjective it's eye-opening and
exciting
what's the model today in video games
video games are interesting because
there have been new waves of technology
but the old wave still exists so the old
way way to buy a video game with
something like madden you pay 60 bucks
or whatever it costs these days that's
still around that business is still
around there's companies like ea that do
that but then you had layered on top of
it all these kind of new more modern
what i think of more modern companies
and like probably the best ones are
things like fortnite and supercell clash
royale and
league of legends these are basically
the model they use is the game is
completely free you can play it
completely
forever
and the only thing you buy are cosmetic
goods
so you can't buy goods that make you win
because people think that would kind of
undermine the integrity of the game so
it's all you know just to look cool
status flex and that's a 40 billion year
industry just the virtual goods alone
and this by the way same thing is going
on nfts it was laughed at 10 years ago
15 years ago it was a big joke of course
it wasn't and it's very important but
you know those virtual goods are kind of
locked into the game also when you buy
the virtual goods all the money is going
to the company so what games like axe
infinity we're investors and it's one of
these kind of new crypto games is
instead of it being you buy the goods
from the company it's much more
peer-to-peer it's much more the way ebay
and craigslist it's you're buying it
from another person who themselves
were able to basically improve the nft
by playing the game and so in the case
of axe you have something on the order
of 100 000 people many of whom are in
the philippines who make a living
playing that game and so they go and
they do a bunch of different stuff and
people call it grinding like you kind of
play a bunch of stuff and then they make
improve the nfts and then other people
who maybe have more money than time
buy them from them and the company only
takes think it's like a three percent
take rate or something as opposed to
much more like a marketplace kind of fee
as opposed to taking all the money the
kind of protocol will take lower fees
but in exchange you've got this like
really kind of cool vibrant economy and
basically like axi really kind of broke
out i think it's one of those four games
that have 800 000 which is the max
discord users and it's one of the four
so it's one of them they think it's like
two million ish active users like very
very popular game by the way not in any
of the app stores because apple and
google are trying to fight web three
bands
and that yet they still have that kind
of user base and i think actually you
know actually is probably the thing that
really inspired a lot of people ygg
mentions the separate company which
we're actually also investors in which
is a it's yield guild games
it's very cool it's almost like a it's a
what's called dao but it's essentially
it's a online software kind of
organization where people can
essentially get loan taxes so they can
go play it and not have to pay the
upfront costs and then earn money so
it's like this kind of guild model that
you have in games where people kind of
get together and join on the same team
but suddenly you can have sort of real
money involved and people make real
livings so i think that the games
industry a lot of sort of the next
generation of talent
saw this and we're excited thank you
chris i'd love to add also just a few
other
i'm not going to give a ton of detail
i'll let people look these folks up but
from the creator standpoint just
bridging back to that
if we think of
nfts i guess on a very very basic level
as
property title of some type there's
actually a lot more that you can sort of
embed into an nft so for instance
dimitri cherniak i'd encourage people to
check out dimitri incredible digital
artist incredible coder really so his
art is
code and
famous for a project and a series of
pieces known as ringers
but also if you check out the eternal
pump as an example and i believe i'm
getting this right if not i'm sure the
internet will correct me and i'll make
amends in the show notes but what an
artist can do is provide
first access to future projects
through certain sets of nfts
and they can also create in real life
interactions or requirements for people
to go to say a certain location to mint
i.e
purchase say a given nft so there are
all these permutations
providing future privileged access
or requiring
real
world actions say to be
eligible to purchase or to receive a
given nft
the sort of cambrian explosion of
experimentation
is beyond anything i've ever seen and
i've been
in tech in one way or another
since
2007 so not that long i guess in the
sort of long term view of things but
i've never seen anything like it
neval do you have anything you'd like to
add there's a really interesting subtle
point that both of you been touching
upon that may be worth making explicit
which is that i think a lot of people
when they first see nfts their reaction
is well i can just right click and save
that jpeg why does this thing have value
and you know hopefully people who look
into nfts move past that pretty quickly
but you're both given examples of how
these things have value that you can't
just right click and save as the
simplest one is just
yes i can also photocopy any piece of
art it doesn't mean that i have the
actual art there's still provenance
there's still a linkage there's still
authenticity to the art itself and the
simplest way to see that is for example
the board yacht club let's say we're
building a metaverse we're building like
a 3d virtual space and hopefully it's
not zuck hopefully it's some crypto
emerging thing on blockchains that we're
all using that's open well if i walk
into two rooms one room has the
authentic board yacht club and it's got
the actual nice photos of the apes or
the crypto punks or whatever hanging on
the walls and my software tells me that
and then i walk into a different room
which has all fakes and copies and my
software immediately tells me now you're
in the fake one where do you think the
cool kids are going to hang out where
are the rich kids going to hang out
where the party's going to take place so
all of a sudden
having nfts and this authentication
gives spaces actual value and so it
allows you to create a metaverse which
then has a distinction between space a
and space b but that's just the simplest
level what you've also given examples of
is in a game an nft is a smart contract
it's a thing that is usable within the
game and a copy of the nft is not if i
have a special piece of loot or a
special item that i've picked up in one
game and then the developer or the same
blockchain or the same group of users
went to a second game and i get to port
my nft over well that authentic nft is
going to have some value whereas a
right-click save jpeg version is not
going to have any value and then finally
tim you give the example of
an nft can also be a social contract
between the creator of the nft and the
fans of the nft so that you get it acts
as a ticket for access to future rights
and a fake one is not going to get you
that or it gives you access to future
pieces by the artist first and so on and
so forth and i love chris example of it
being a web page because the web page is
programmable a web page can do anything
it can it's touring complete it can run
any piece of code and so we have these
essentially touring complete
programmable objects that are now
suddenly scarce that you can own and
that you can transfer and you can link
to the real world and you can link them
to the digital world through smart
contracts you can link them to the real
world through social contracts by the
way bitcoin is only linked to the real
world through social contracts i know
that's gonna be a controversial thing to
say but essentially it's a social
contract between the community of
bitcoiners to accept bitcoin to accept
that as a canonical ledger so the same
way among the board ape community or
among the crypto punk community or
whatever the toads or the frogs or
whoever they are whichever community
there is a social contract to accept
these as the canonical avatars so
essentially what blockchains do is they
allow open composability and
programmability between all these
objects in the digital domain and
there's those smart contracts that
regulate those and then social contracts
that regulate in the outside world and
nft is no different if bitcoin can have
value if a theorem can have value then
in theory an nft can have value as long
as the smart contracts the social
contracts the community enforcing it
have value of course that means most of
them aren't but some of them will i want
to also come back to so rare for a
second and i'm an investor in a few
funds that have
staked in so rare that's not why i bring
it up i bring it up because i listen to
a podcast
a guy named andrew steinwald
on zima red interviewing i'm blanking in
his last name but his first name is aj
who was i believe a data scientist at
amazon who then went on to become a so
rare player so let me explain for a
second i'm not going to do it justice
but if you
can imagine collecting and this is again
not going to do it justice and either of
you should correct me if i get this
wrong but
digital trading cards that represent
specific players
that you can assemble into teams
that are then benchmarked against real
world sports performance
to determine how well your team does
with said team you can win money in
leagues of different types now people
are like okay fine sports betting
interesting but where it starts to get
super super interesting
is because it's correlated to
real world play
with these composite teams you then have
right now for instance
funds being created where they're hiring
effectively digital sports managers
they're buying and loaning out these
players these nfts
and
then
doubling down on the people who perform
best as sports managers and one of their
dream
goals is at some point to take all of
this sports analytics intelligence
and data science and to buy an actual
sports team and to apply it there kind
of like sabermetrics and the oakland a's
and billy bean back in the day but in an
environment where they can simulate and
test and split test and multivariate
test over and over and over and over
again
i'll give one other example of things to
come and maybe it's already happening
you guys could probably speak to this
but
let's say you buy a piece of artwork
that is in the form of a digital nft
and i suppose that's a redundant term
but in the form of an nft
right now
if you need a loan
you might secure that loan with
collateral such as your home
and if it's not happening already in the
near future people will be able to do
that with
collateral of high value
that is secured and verified on the
blockchain right you're not going to
have to go to sotheby's and get all the
provenance and the letters and this and
that which is going to take forever
you'll be able to instantly verify it
and then secure loans against something
like a high value nft could be a ringer
could be a fedenza it could be a crypto
punk could be anything i mean they're
going to be many different options
and i think those are things that just
are not immediately apparent they
certainly weren't immediately apparent
to me when kevin rose was the first
person to show me crypto punks and i was
just flabbergasted
but when you start to i mean look
they're cool i i think they're amazing
on a bunch of levels but it's
deceptively simple on the surface and
the implications are unbelievably
nuanced so i just wanted to give a few
of those examples
yeah i just want to drop one quote in
here which is floats around on the
internet it's called gaul's law it's a
rule of thumb for systems design and it
basically says that a complex system
designed from scratch never works and
cannot be patched to make it work a
complex system that works is invariably
found to evolve from a simple system
that worked so in that sense nfts are
primitive and people are going to
recombine and assemble and compose these
primitives to create incredibly complex
systems and everyone who competes with
nfts with a centralized solution as
happens inside every game or every
social network is trying to design a
complex system from the top down and
it's kind of a miracle that even works
so this is all part of the
decentralization user ownership
revolution of web3 we own the nfts
they're simple they're portable they're
programmable they're composable and
people are going to recombine them to
create these complex systems that work
that are going to be impossible for
larger companies to compete with and we
can already see that apple and google
don't like nfts and so you're not going
to see a lot of web3 applications on the
phones anytime soon and even i think
recently it was valve which runs steam
the game distribution service so that
they're not going to have nfts on there
or nft based games on there and they're
going to miss out they're going to miss
out on the largest boom in internet
gaming since the beginning of internet
gaming chris i'd love to ask you a
question thank you naval
to come back to a word that you used and
uh we've spoken about this separately on
the phone because i wanted to know how
the hell to pronounce this word
skeuomorphic
yeah all right so skeuomorphic maybe you
could give maybe some historical
examples of like skeuomorphic design and
what that means
and you've written before that one of
the most common mistakes people make
when evaluating new technologies is to
focus too much on doing old things
better so i imagine we are seeing and
we'll see a lot of people are trying to
copy and paste web one or two for web3
so i'd love for you to just
spell and then give some examples of
skew morphic design and then after that
to give some examples if you can
of sort of web three
native slash emergent
applications or instances to just
illustrate what might be possible
yeah so i didn't know the respelling on
this
on this pocket skt
so it was i think it was a steve jobs
word that he used this word and he used
it to refer to visual design so if you
remember the original iphone had like a
book gap and it had wood grained
bookshelves and so it was this concept
and design of taking something from the
offline world and using that design in
the online world to make it look more
familiar for whatever reason me and my
colleagues started using this word all
the time internally like three or four
years ago i'm not sure if we invented it
or got it i mean that meant it but like
sort of ported it over from the design
world i don't really remember but we'd
always use it to mean you go back and
look at early films and early films
looked like plays they'd put people on
and they would walk around and they
stage it like plays and then over time
kind of film developed its own kind of
new grammar and so you had a close-up
and you had an establishing shot you go
look at the old movies they would just
show grand central station for like 10
minutes and they learned over time you
could just show it for like a second and
the human brain would figure it out and
this happens with every
every new technology the first cars they
mimicking the horses and and so the
early web for example right it was like
brochures and magazines so the opposite
we call it sort of native so you can do
kind of web native stuff like it can be
a two-way medium it can it's code you
can do all sorts of other kind of cool
stuff
so i think it wasn't until kind of the
mid-2000s that people really started
exploring the quote native web
experience and i believe it the best
investment approach was to bet on the
native stuff so i remember when youtube
was out it was sort of two classes of
video apps there was the youtube ones
and then there was these other ones
which were basically saying hey we're
going to take cbs and put it on the
internet enterprise software kind of
model people remember there weren't
youtube stars back then so it was all
these just kind of silly viral videos or
things that infringed on copyright
probably right so when they got bought
by google that was really controversial
because it was the widespread meme kind
of like crypto today it's all this shady
dark illegal stuff but what they
understood the founders
and google to their credit is that this
was the true native video on the
internet and that once you created this
experience this thing where you could
embed the videos and it worked
seamlessly and there weren't permission
paywalls all around it that this huge
creator community would come up around
it and you'd have this whole new and now
today dude perfect guys messing around
the basketball stuff or whatever and
didn't exist back then has more
subscribers than all the sports leagues
combined on youtube it's not not only
were the native products the winners but
the native creators with the winners and
so this is a concept we use a lot
internally people who know me will tell
you i always when i'm negative on
something it's because it's geomorphic
people want to take blockchains and do
like supply chain management offline
ticketing
these are sorry i'm glad they're
entrepreneurs in every category and i
respect all entrepreneurs but those are
skeomorphic ideas i think and they may
work but they're not going to be the
thing people talk about 10 years from
now it's going to be this new stuff the
nft so let me give you an example of a
really cool project there's a thing
called loop i haven't heard of loot is
this game loot by the former creator of
or i guess the creator of vine yeah yeah
dom hoffman who's a genius
developer and
product designer
created this thing loot and what loot is
is basically it's just these little
cards that have an inventory like kind
of a dungeon dragon style game so it'll
say magic cloak just literally those
words on the page and those themselves
are nfts but what's so cool about it is
that it inspired this whole community of
people to build around it it's almost
like if you know ernest hemingway
instead of writing the book wrote just
the first page of the book and then let
the community kind of add the next page
and so that's what gom is he wrote this
is the beginning of it now let your
imaginations go wild and by the way
there won't be one canonical game
there'll be a hundred different things
that all kind of use they're in the loop
verse
it's this whole tapestry of creative
people adding
different bricks into this new structure
and that's just a very profound new way
to think about building a game and
something you couldn't have done without
as naval called it these very simple new
building blocks and exactly the
simplicity that makes them so powerful
and that the way you can recombine them
and that's just an early experiment
there will be many more cool experiments
like that but what's cool about that
experiment what do they say like the
velvet underground or something had only
a thousand fans but they all started
vans kind of thing luke doesn't have
like millions of users but the people
that like it are the best product
designers in the world i think it's
going to be one of those moments where
in the same way novel you remember this
delicious and flicker there was a period
of like 2003 to five and kind of all the
core web 2 primitive stuff happened and
people was like oh my god like tagging i
mean it sounds sounds hilarious today
tagging was like a breakthrough it was a
conceptual breakthrough because before
that it was like oh you have to have
categories everything has to be mutually
exclusive bucket there's every website
had this thing on the left everything
had to be in a bucket and tagging teams
like no it doesn't it's like you have a
computer with a lot of with a lot of
powerful capabilities you can just make
a tag and then default public that was a
revolutionary concept so there was this
period i think we're in that kind of
period now in this world where there's
like this really really kind of creative
core that's developing these cool ideas
and those will be provide kind of the
road map for the next wave yeah the
flickers will lead to the pinterest
exactly yeah your skeomorphic idea it
runs even a little deeper and
skeuomorphism can work too like if you
look at basic computers we use a desktop
computing paradigm there's a desktop
there's files there's folders that's
geomorphism from the physical world and
it can help people to reason by analogy
into how to use something but at the
same time i actually share chris's
skepticism with skeuomorphism in this
space in fact i made a big mistake which
is early on in the history of
blockchains i thought we're going to do
is we're going to replace uber and
facebook and twitter with web3 enabled
primitives and networks that come out of
those now i don't necessarily think so i
think we're just gonna create brand new
things that we can't yet even predict or
identify but we're gonna end up shifting
our attention to those things so twitter
and facebook will still be fine will
continue to exist but our attention will
be on these new applications that are
uniquely enabled by primitives like nfts
and tokens i think that's right i think
like look i mean people still use
microsoft office it's still around the
internet didn't get rid of it i think
these are just layers and layers and i
think the same thing i agree the value
is created in the cool stuff will be in
the native kind of cutting edge stuff on
the frontier
yes let me make a couple recommendations
for folks who are listening to a book
and a movie recommendation and you guys
might make fun of me for this but the
first is go
read snow crash and appreciate how
prescient that book was uh and it's an
enjoyable read neil stephenson
incredible book but
go check that out and then perhaps at
the same time or even beforehand
watch or re-watch ready player one
and
certainly there are aspects of it that i
don't think are right around the corner
but i think a lot is coming sooner than
people expect that is what i've
at least come away with
conditionally at this point having
immersed myself for the last few months
very very deep down the rabbit hole
and
with that though i want to
play
proxy for listeners for saying okay well
we're hearing about all of the amazing
things
what are some of the
weaknesses or challenges associated with
web3 and i'll start with one so i
remember
purchasing some of these nfts
and then having someone recommend that i
share that online and i go wait a second
if i share it online then people are
effectively looking into my bank account
full of assets that are worth certain
amounts
and all of that is preserved in the
blockchain and they're like that's right
you're your own bank and i'm like uh i'm
not sure if i 100 want to be my own bank
in the sense that people use external
banks for a lot of good reasons right
they don't want to have gold bars and
money stuck into a mattress in their own
house and have to deal with home defense
and so on i do think it appears there
are some sort of technical
solutions or services coming that could
address some of these things i'm just
wondering i've been to your house tim i
think your your home defense is pretty
good yeah my home defense is fine that's
true i think but i'm i'm in edge case
right so not everyone has like multiple
firearms placed in multiple locations
that's a longer conversation it's uh not
because i'm a crazy person although some
people would disagree but
the
question is like what are some of the
challenges because there have been
points where i'm like okay would i
prefer amazon to see my entire purchase
history or would i prefer the entire
internet to possibly see my entire
purchase history i don't know i at this
point in time for me personally probably
amazon and will the solutions that come
to address some of those concerns once
we get to
millions of wallets instead of say 500
000 wallets engaging with certain types
of nfts
will those services be antithetical to
the ethos and promise of web3 so i just
want to throw that out there and hear
whatever comes to mind for you guys
for me security is a big issue i've been
outspoken about crypto for quite a while
so i had to very carefully move all of
my investments into custodians and funds
so that i don't hold anything directly
but this is only possible because you
can be your own bank but the good news
is you can be your own bank in very
limited circumstances you can take the
majority of it you can stick it with
custodians and just like there's places
you can store your physical art
undergarden lock and key you'll be able
to put your nfts at least the valuable
ones into nft armories and repositories
there's going to be a multi-signature
where multiple people have to agree to
move something there will be time delay
where it can't be moved for six months
or a year so we can help mitigate all
that and the industry is working on all
of that too slowly for my comfort but
it's happening
you can also keep your anonymity in
multiple ways we mentioned punk6529 who
is a purely twitter identity people
don't know who that person is in real
life but they're already regarded as a
good nft collector and curator you can
also create new wallets on the fly and
the software is getting better and
better for that so you can literally do
each purchase out of a different wallet
which may be hard to trace the previous
one because there are enough ways to
anonymize it at least from the general
public or if you're using things like
zero knowledge proofs from almost
anybody so these problems will get
solved but there are problems today
which is kind of what makes this space
hairy when the time comes that anyone
can mint and hold and move in nft easily
it'll be a joyous moment but also a lot
of the so-called alpha in the space will
be gone
yeah chris steve anything you'd like to
add yeah i agree with that and i think
related closely related security of
course is usability and just how to make
everything easy to use and secure i
think it'll all get worked out but i
agree with naval that it's not there yet
to me the biggest challenge in the space
is probably the messaging around it i
think there's a lot of misunderstandings
around it i think some of that is sort
of self-inflicted by us by the community
i think some of it is just hasn't
diffused out into the broader world so
you just have a lot of people who
react negatively to crypto web 3 etc and
i think that could also lead to
overzealous regulatory actions too and
so i think that
is i think it's very important
to do i think what we're trying to do
here and just sort of explain these
ideas i think ultimately what usually
convinces people is they need to kind of
decide for themselves they want to
dive into it i've literally in eight
years in the space i have never met
somebody who's very well informed on the
space and also deeply skeptical
never if you're deeply skeptical about
the idea of owning digital property then
you don't understand it you're not only
denying capitalism on the internet
you're a metaverse denier because if you
look at the metaverse as articulated in
neil stevens the snow crash or almost
anywhere else there is this concept of
there is property in the metaverse and
obviously some people own property and
there's jurisdiction within that
property it's not just you can enter
into my room because i can just right
click and copy and save your room
there's authenticity around this is my
room these are my objects in my room and
i can shuffle them around i can control
who comes in and out and i can control
what happens when someone tries to quote
unquote sit on my metaverse couch are
they allowed to do that or not so all of
this programmability comes from
ownership and it's a bizarre idea to
think that the only people who can own
items in the metaverse are big
corporations you're basically saying
only zak no offense to zuck i actually
think he does a better job than he has
credit for but your basically says only
zuck is allowed to own the metaverse
only he can own the entire metaverse why
can't we each own our own room our own
space our own property in the metaverse
so denying and pushing back against nfts
and cryptos is basically saying we're
not going to have a collectively owned
future we're going to have a corporate
owned future and we're going to have a
government future i can see why the
chinese communist party wants to ban
crypto because it is antithetical to the
idea of users owning things but for a
capitalist society for democratic
society for a collective society to ban
crypto that makes no sense to me for it
to ban nfts or try to put them into
financial regulations which essentially
ban it is basically saying no you
artists are not allowed to own your own
output and deal directly with the fans
you have to be serfs working on
spotify's farms or working on youtube's
farm this might be
a complete 90 degree turn but i'm gonna
ask anyway and we'll see where it goes
going back to one of your many
many many posts
at cdixon.org
this is an oldie 2009.
um
[Music]
yeah yeah i know you're about to get
cancelled no we're not going to get yeah
one very very questionable paragraph no
that's not what i'm gonna do
what is hill climbing in computer
science so hill climbing it's a class of
kind of algorithms the metaphor is think
of a landscape with a bunch of pills
and the goal is to get to the highest
point but put this constraint on let's
say it's foggy you can only see a little
bit in front of you behind you and so
there's a class of algorithms that sort
of basically talk about what's the
optimal way to climb that hill
one obvious one is if you're on an
incline go up but the problem there is
you might get trapped in what's called a
local maxima which is you just happen to
start on a small hill the next iteration
of that is what's called simulated
annealing which is you add some
randomness in there too to sort of avoid
just simply going up the first hill and
so this post i wrote i think you're
talking to this is a popular post
it's called climbing the wrong hill and
i was making the analogy from these
algorithms to a career and the idea was
just like in a career you do want to
sort of climb the hill you're on but the
mistake i saw a lot of young people
making was
they're at mckinsey or google or
something and they see kind of the next
prize is six months away the next
promotion the next bonus whatever it is
and they kind of are on that treadmill
and not willing to go for example join a
startup and take us what appears to be a
step backwards but is in fact a much
bigger hill and they get caught up in
the kind of local maximization thing and
end up and i think you find a lot of
people who are unhappy in their careers
when they're in their 30s and 40s it's
because they hill climbed the wrong hill
the lesson i take from the computer
science is to add some randomness to
some exploration there's a concept of
machine learning it's called exploration
versus exploitation you want to always
have a balance between for example i try
to use this when i order food so i will
make sure that sometimes i'm exploiting
exploiting means i'm going to my
favorite restaurant but at half the time
i'm also trying a new restaurant
this is a core concept in machine
learning when you design new systems
it's sort of how to optimally kind of
come to conclusion so
that's the idea a little bit it's just
you should have i think people in their
20s for example should add not
randomness not literally randomness but
exploration they should go try a bunch
of different things see what's the right
hill and also be willing to take a step
back yeah you want to keep your schedule
open as much as possible so you can
follow your own natural intellectual
curiosity i mean ironically the best
career of 2021 was to be a jpeg
collector
and i figured this out too late but it's
hilarious how many of my friends have
gotten rich collecting and flipping
jpegs and the best career of 2020 was
probably to be a defy yield farmer
whatever the heck that means go google
that so it's insane but the world is
moving so fast adapting so quickly the
frontiers in crypto it's digital if you
have a natural intellectual curiosity
about any of these things your moment
will come it may turn out actually with
the axi people and the ygg people
that the best upcoming career the best
current career might have to do around
gaming just playing a game a certain way
at a certain time good news for all the
gamers out there yeah i want to read
two paragraphs from that blog post which
is climbing the wrong hill
fantastic memory
and i should say the
context is you're discussing
hypothetical job candidate
but the lure of the current hill is
strong there's a natural human tendency
to make the next step an upward one he
ends up falling for a common trap
highlighted by behavioral economists
people tend to systematically
overvalue near-term over long-term
rewards this effect seems to be even
stronger and more ambitious people their
ambition seems to make it hard for them
to forgo the nearby upward step
people early in their career should
learn from computer science meander some
in your walk especially early on
randomly drop yourself into new parts of
the terrain and when you find the
highest hill don't waste any more time
on the current hill no matter how much
better the next step might appear
so i wanted to read this
in part because
in the last few months
paying attention to web 3 which i feel
is late but that's only because my pure
group
is very weird
and an edge case i feel like it's not
even the end of the first inning not
even close it's like the anthem before
the game has even started and i have
never seen so many highly intelligent
ambitious
capable people drop whatever they are
doing in many cases really attractive
things
to dedicate all of their time to this
i've never seen
anything approaching it on mass it's not
a trickle that
slowly builds to more than a trickle i
mean it's people immediately deciding
this is what they want to spend
24 7 on
i don't know perhaps i just don't have a
macro perspective over a long enough
period of time but certainly
in all of my time
in or around
technology i've just never seen anything
like it and at the very least that means
it's something that's worth taking a
very close look at
yeah the big danger here of course is
the final boss crypto and web 3 have not
gone mainstream yet they're in their
infancy i don't know what it's like 10
million wallets or something out there
among americans or even globally
yeah it's small it's in the tens of
millions so we have to move to the
hundreds of millions and eventually
billions and has to go through the same
adoption curve that web 2 and web one
did and in theory it could even go
faster as long as there aren't too many
obstacles in the way because tokens
naturally have incentive mechanism built
in as chris pointed out the token
companies don't need to do much
marketing the marketing is done by the
users
and so
the problem is that where we started was
we actually decentralized the hardest
thing the hardest thing to decentralize
is money and once you have money
decentralized then you can own private
property but essentially decentralizing
money threatens the nation state because
a central bank currency central bank
digital currency is the exact opposite
of a cryptocurrency that's the complete
centralization of money with no
intermediary banks or monetary
instruments under the eye of the
all-seeing state and on the other hand
you have people just carrying their own
money around whether as a coin or as a
jpeg or as a smart contract or as an iou
or some kind of a weird program
and unfortunately we're trying to apply
laws that are almost 100 years old to
try and regulate this incredible
explosion in internet commerce and
market making in digital private
property and they're just not going to
get it and we recently have a very
aggressive sec and cftc that are now
fighting to extend their domain and i
think we end up in an upside-down
situation where innovation in the space
gets driven overseas underground and out
into the internet where it will still
succeed because the natural end point of
crypto is maximum decentralization and
maximum privacy it's going to just make
it happen a lot faster it's going to
make it happen outside the united states
so the web 3 revolution could happen
outside of the united states one of the
big problems with being a web 3 investor
or even user these days is the kyc
around the wallets around the purchases
around the sales the fact that a lot of
these coins you can't participate in
their offerings you have to have
offshore entities or more likely be a
non-us citizen to even get into these
it's becoming very very restrictive and
all we seem to be focused on is investor
protection and not at all in innovation
or creation or creativity and i know
chris and his team have been fighting
the good fight and a16z crypto has
probably done more work than anybody on
the regulatory front backed up by people
like coin center and so on but they put
a lot of work into it
i also want to
chime in as a luddite who's just barely
finding
his footing or losing his footing with
some water wings at the very least but
it also strikes me that
as you said chris
sometimes the true believers can be
their own worst enemies
in the sense that people still use word
i still use
what people might consider
legacy tools every day
and
these
technologies or these currencies are not
mutually exclusive and i i think that
it behooves
the communities who are
adopting and developing these tools
for many reasons
to
be more inclusive with their
consideration of having multiple options
viable
into the future which i think is
inevitable on some level
and certainly it is unhelpful and
counterproductive
to
overstate the case for the eradication
of
central
everything
most people don't want to pave their own
streets or handle their own garbage
disposal i mean there are valuable
services provided by
the state and it's hard to appreciate
the full value until it's taken away if
anyone was here in austin during the
freeze you realize very quickly
how dependent we are on many of the
services that are provided and i think
there is and will be certainly for a
very long time
a role for
centralized banks and that if people in
fact want these technologies to continue
to develop and i think that many
regulators may feel like they're caught
between a rock and a hard place
in part because the messaging is so
exclusive from the kind of die hard and
true believers often times
but the as naval you said
the economic case for allowing
a thousand flowers to bloom
in the web3 ecosystem within the united
states is hard to overstate at least
that's what it seems like to me
yeah any any regulator that stops the
next generation of artists and musicians
and gamers and game developers
from owning their platforms and their
work is going to go into the waste
basket of history as a villain
it's that simple yeah and to your point
tim i think that some of this was sort
of self-inflicted and particularly
around there's certain we call maxis
people that are into certain tokens and
i think only that token should exist so
there's bitcoin maximalist there's
ethereum max you know et cetera those
folks are just they tend to be kind of
loud and
somewhat aggressive and i think that's
done a lot a lot of the branding in the
space of sort of people's common view of
crypto has comes from some of those
folks who
some of them like in the bitcoin world
are they have a political angle to it
there's sort of this libertarian aspect
to bitcoin and i think as a result
particularly as we're seeing now that
the democratic side thinks of crypto as
the enemy
when i think that the stuff we're
talking about the web3 stuff is actually
very very aligned with i think a lot of
the
left agenda which is
better distribution of wealth reigning
in the power of some of the big tech
companies the difference is we're
arguing to do it through innovation and
competition
not through regulation which won't work
by the way if they cut up facebook with
three networks it's not going to change
anything it's exactly the same thing
it's instagram's still going to be
instagram and the economics are going to
be the same
and it's going to be just a centralized
that's just not going to work the thing
that will work is let innovators and
entrepreneurs go build a better internet
that's what we want to do it's not to me
this is not a political movement in that
sense it's a technology movement
and it's somehow gotten
associated with politics things in this
country right now it's very heated in
the political world everything is
politicized that's a big challenge we
have is just to really kind of go and
explain these things i think the good
news is we have truth on our side
everything i'm saying here and
everything i've tweeted is
mathematically provable
including the fact that a blockchain's a
computer and the power of this new
paradigm but there's a lot of
communications
challenges ahead so let me ask both of
you and maybe i'll start with you chris
if there are
which i know there are at least
certainly in the broader
listenership broader audience
regulators lawmakers policymakers and
i've met a lot of these people and i
think part of the challenge
is simply becoming educated from
reliable sources when it is so
difficult i mean it's difficult
bordering on impossible for me to
separate signal from noise if i'm trying
to just take it through a funnel like
sort of waterboarding of information and
i would like to ask you if there are any
particular
resources or
could be essays books anything where
people in those positions
could start to begin to understand
the fundamentals of what we're
discussing
one of the things we've tried to do is
create materials for this so we have for
example which i could share the link
afterwards it's like a 35 page overview
for
for policy makers
great that kind of talks about the
benefits and things like that so we've
been trying to create materials like
that i think it's one of the things been
lacking is just all the good things
they've all talked about earlier the
meaning the twitter stuff everything
else it's what's wonderful about this
world is sort of the chaos but at the
same time it's also useful to have a
30-page booklet sometimes so that's what
we've tried to do kind of add that a
little bit on there so yeah so we've
tried to create a bunch of materials to
sort of explain it our firm we believe
in innovation and we believe in america
a lot of other people in crypto will do
things with offshore entities and things
we don't we tell people you should be
based in the u.s you should be a u.s
company pay u.s taxes unit swap there in
new york city they have a
an office in soho they hire people from
new york they go to their office we have
some european investments and things but
most of our our investments are here in
america and i believe
hayden adams
who's the founder of unit swap robert
lesnar the founder of compound
the openc founders all of these other
founders in our portfolio i believe
they're heroes i believe they are heroes
who are on the cutting edge of the
frontier and creating very important
technology that will transform the
internet and i believe that over time
more people will come to to realize that
these are people in the mold of the
steve jobs or henry ford this is how
america stays ahead we believe this
completely and we believe this is
critical for the future of the internet
and critical for the future of this
country that's why we're investing so
much in i'm just going to add one thing
for people who are listening i'll create
a short link it'll be live by the time
you hear this tim dot blog slash dixon
and that will take everyone to the show
notes and we'll include a link to the
booklet that you mentioned chris naval
sorry for interrupting no problem yeah
the united states became the most
powerful country in the world for many
reasons but recently it's been because
we are the home of creative technology
most creative technology on the planet
comes from the united states now is that
because we create all the entrepreneurs
no we attract all of the entrepreneurs
because we had the most freedom
technology entrepreneurs are creative
people and they want to go where they
are the most free to create new things
and so if we stop being a gravitational
attractor for the best entrepreneurs on
the planet we're eventually going to
lose our technological leadership and
that means we will not be able to pay
for our extravagant social programs we
won't have the abundance and the
deflationary
drive that technology innovation and
productivity growth have provided so i'm
just concerned because i do talk to a
lot of entrepreneurs now we're overseas
most investing these days is done over
zoom it's no longer done physically in
the san francisco bay area especially in
web 3 and crypto land mostly
entrepreneurs are overseas and now
almost none of them in their right mind
are considering moving to the united
states which before if you're in china
or india the default would have been i'm
going to move to california or to the
united states and now it's like well
maybe i'll go to miami maybe i'll stop
in in the u.s but no more likely i'm
going to singapore or i'm going to
switzerland or i'm staying anonymous on
the web or i'm going to be on some
little island nation just moving around
this is really really bad news for all
the people who are counting on their
pension plans to pay out in valuable u.s
dollars because the only solution we
seem to have in the last two years to
the covet phenomenon is devaluing the
dollar there was a funny line that went
on twitter or somebody said now we know
what would happen if aliens invaded the
earth the fed would cut interest rates
and that seems to be our answer to every
crisis cut interest rates print more
money well that's selling the asset that
we already have eventually you run out
the beauty of our model is that the
entire world uses the us dollar as its
stable currency as its ultimate stable
coin and so every time we print a dollar
70 cents of that dilution that inflation
goes overseas but that's eventually
going to go away we can't just keep
printing our way out of problems we
actually have to create we have to
innovate we have to improve productivity
and that means that the next generation
of technological innovation has to be
based here where they can pay their
taxes where they want to live and spend
and eat and consume here and i'm just
concerned that all the combination of
ambiguous and aggressive regulations
where
regulators who are purely financial
regulators are now getting their claws
on the web and are going to regulate
this thing into overseas you can't stop
it it's ultimately code and code is just
speech and speeches ideas you can't stop
ideas you can push them down one place
and they'll pop up somewhere else and
the internet is a big place so short of
turning off the entire internet the
internet will figure out how to create
store allocate and use digital value and
that's exactly what's going on and if
you try to stop that you're just going
to miss out on the greatest wealth
creation and innovation since the
internet itself came into being look
naval and i we could very easily invest
another country we don't want to i mean
frankly like when you're investors it's
not it's easy to move around and invest
other places and things like this i just
think it'd be a real shame if that's the
outcome let me add to that for just a
second and what i like to add to that is
number one
there are many ways to easily
incentivize innovators to create things
here we don't sort of go through the
playbook but regulators policymakers i
think have a pretty good
idea of what the historically effective
approaches are and i want to come back
to that in a second
we've already seen what happens when
things get locked down in a place like
china and this is obviously a ball in
play but a lot of people will just
relocate if they can depending on many
different factors but you see a lot of
hotbeds popping up in places like
there's like a there's a ton in
singapore yeah they're all chinese yeah
china trying to stop bitcoin mining no
then they all went to singapore now
they're doing crypto in singapore all
the chinese yeah exactly all the bitcoin
mining has moved the us actually the
chinese ban on bitcoin mining the huge
beneficiary was the united states yeah
exactly and there are some i was just
chatting with biology about this
separate podcast and he was commenting
on for instance
how bitcoin may in fact be a way for
certain types of renewable energy
that have high volatility such as
wind or solar
to store
energy in the form of bitcoin utilizing
that energy even if it's not being
consumed
so there are some really interesting
applications that are non-obvious but i
would like to just
ask if there are because we've been
talking about what policy makers and
regulators shouldn't do and we've given
maybe a few
sentences to what they should do are
there any policy makers or people in
government whether that's federal state
level city level
who are
worth mentioning and commending for
actually taking positive actions
patrick mchenry and the house financial
services committee has been very
forward-looking on crypto christian
cinema from arizona said kind of the
right things and i think she's also done
some work in here
i'm sure chris is probably more up to
speed but andrew yang recently was
talking about it in a positive way
look i think there's a lot of
politicians and policy makers and things
who do understand this and what we would
like so there's been a couple things one
there's just been no clarity so like
there's sort of two ways that regulators
regulate and one is through
stating policies and one is through
enforcement and so far it's all been
just through enforcement and so people
just don't know what to do and as a
result like so one of the big myths in
crypto is it's unregulated okay i will
tell you we have more regulators and
policing lawyers and things i've
practically become a lawyer i spend so
much time on this stuff the first thing
we do in every company we invest in is
help them recruit a general counsel they
all spend millions of dollars on outside
counsel everyone wants to be as
compliant as they can obviously it's a
very strong incentive for them to do so
there's lots of regulations that apply
to these companies including consumer
protection laws commodities laws etc
and no one questions that and they have
to they all have to have policies and
adhere to those things there's specific
questions around things like what
qualifies an asset to be a security or
not these are topics that we've spent
years on in countless legal resources
analyzing working on but the way that
the regulators have chosen to enforce
this is not through guidance but through
this seemingly
hard to understand set of enforcement
actions as an example so i think clarity
would be great i think
probably a lot of this has to happen at
the policy level i think modernizing a
lot of these things as involved saying
these rules are from like the 1930s and
40s
and a lot of them just involve very
not tech modern practices like putting
your driver's license in front of a
thing that has like a 50 failure rate
for kyc or something let's modernize
these things so that's that's one of the
things we're working on is what's the
crypto native way to modernize a lot of
these processes and get the goal like
the goals are very good like securities
laws makes a lot of sense so securities
law is all around situations where
there's asymmetric information
and when there's asymmetric information
because there's a centralized entity
that has knowledge of things you need to
have rules around disclosing that
information securities laws are a set of
rules around liability and disclosure to
make sure there's a level information
playing field that makes a lot of sense
we like that and we think a great way to
not have asymmetric information is to
have no company that's a really good way
to have isometric information the sec
has the same goal we have which is let's
get rid of these intermediaries they do
it for asymmetric information reasons
we're doing it for other ideological
reasons as we discussed here but it's
very aligned i think it works very
nicely actually
the challenge right now as i was saying
before is much more of a communication
challenge i think if we can go and talk
to folks
and show one what the socially
beneficial thing uses of this technology
is
having creators who are making
a living and all sorts of other things
like that are very important for that
reason and then also just sort of
explain and show that the the goals are
aligned and that we don't want a
situation where i mean
no one wants situation where there's
sort of asymmetric information and bad
stuff happening and there's money
involved as with all sort of tech things
and money involved there are bad people
for sure it's just inevitable it
happened in the 90s it happened in the
2000s it happens now
and those people give
web 3 a very bad name we want to get rid
of those people i think that the goals
are actually
much more aligned
maybe i'm being overly optimistic but i
feel like it's a communication problem
the 1999 2000 tech bubble
was the small price that we had to pay
in exchange for being the home for
creative technological innovation in the
world and we got facebook and google and
amazon and netflix and a long tail of
incredible companies and innovations in
exchange
and the same way we're going to have to
suffer through a little bit of the pump
and the
boom in crypto and in web 3 and
hopefully the sec and the cftc can be
modern and lightfooted enough that they
crack down on the obvious scams but they
sort of let a cambrian explosion happen
as well where people can innovate and
try things and once the dust settles and
once it's clear that we're won and
what's fair and unfair that's sort of
the right time for them to go in and put
on guard rails for the average user but
putting on those guard rails too early
on just means you miss out the best
venture investment actually of like the
last decade was probably ethereum 2014
ethereum went out there and you could
have bought it for 30 cents and you
would have been liquid and ironically
vcs were the ones who couldn't
participate because their fun docs
didn't allow them to participate but the
non-vcs could
and just kind of closing those doors and
saying well that's not going to happen
again
you know it makes a couple of mistakes
it pushes us out of the united states it
keeps the poor poor and makes the rich
richer because people like chris and i
can always set up entities to
participate and then it also pushes the
whole ecosystem further underground more
into decentralization more into privacy
more into anonymity when the stated
goals of regulators are actually
they want users to own and control their
own data data privacy and data
protection is a big thing regulators
care about well crypto enables that
uniquely you own your private keys
another thing they care about is
interoperability they want there to be
open api so there's a single monopolist
sitting in the middle well that's
composability composability is the
ultimate open api so i think there is a
model here for an enlightened regulator
to do the right thing and get just as
much credit for letting web3 flourish as
the original set of regulators did for
web one and frankly they should have
been more celebrated more recognized
yeah let me add to that because i've
been involved with a number of things
now including
and this is actually very related oddly
enough let's say funding scientific
research into treatments for
end-of-life anxiety due to terminal
cancer diagnoses and things like this
that there people have individual
philanthropists have sometimes avoided
certain types of scientific studies
involving say intractable or so-called
intractable
psychiatric conditions and ultimately
i was able to show through my own
example
that
there was not
just a lack of reputational risk or
minimal reputational risk and there may
be i don't say that doesn't exist but
there was much more reputational upside
potential
and i think that's important not just
saying like we can minimize the risk of
say policymaker talking about this but
then in fact i think there are ways to
position it which comes back to coms and
determining the way that things are
communicated but i think there is
four
people who look at this closely and
really gain an understanding tremendous
reputational upside and i'll give a
couple of examples one people have
already heard and that is what got me
interested in all of this was the fact
that friends of mine who were
in some cases close to broke or who had
been limping along barely able to make
ends meet
as
creatives and artists
have suddenly been able to do
what they're called to do which is
create artwork make it commercially
viable
share ownership with
a
flourishing community
and then receive residual payment for
the works that they've created
and if we bridge that to what i was just
saying about the scientific work so i
have a foundation it's not a huge
foundation it's a small private
foundation and i've been very aggressive
with funding
i think important science and some of
those studies have ended up on the cover
of nature others have ended up on the
cover of the new york times it's been
really effective but i don't have
enough to call it say an endowment so
i'm basically just spending principle
instead of working off of the earnings
the investment earnings of the money in
the foundation so every year i'm just
trying to basically
patch the boat back together and keep it
moving
what is possible and i'm hoping to prove
this is really viable because i would
love for others to be able to emulate
this is i could launch an nft project
and who knows what form that will take
but
to launch an nft project where 100 of
the proceeds go to my foundation and
there are different ways that this could
work
where a wallet is owned by either
directly by the foundation or through a
daf or something like that but here's
the important part the important part
the exciting part for me is not just
that
cryptocurrency or ethereum could be
donated to the foundation it's that i
could launch a project that then
continues to generate
proceeds that go directly right i don't
have the head count i don't have a team
to handle this for me and the beauty is
that with smart contracts i don't need
any of that i launch a project and then
automatically when things are resold by
the people who originally bought and
then sold again and sold again and sold
again hopefully for increasingly high
prices
that that continues
to provide lifeblood to this foundation
that is doing life-changing work for
veterans with complex ptsd i've done a
number of collaborations with say the
navy seal foundation all of these
causes need funding
mostly from individual philanthropists
and it's [ __ ] hard to do it is hard
to make work
and nfts to me offer a possible vehicle
for actually making it
sustainable and allowing me to scale and
do more with that so i just wanted to
mention all that to kind of bring it
home like why the hell would i spend all
this time on this i don't have a high
burn lifestyle like i'm wearing the
cheapest jeans you can imagine and shoes
that somebody gave to me right like
i don't spend a lot of money but
i want to be able to do more and i want
to involve my community in a way
that they've been asking for for a long
time but they want to give to say
support causes or phase three trials but
none of these entities these
universities or researchers are equipped
to handle small donations
so i can do that and these are a lot of
reasons why
i was excited to have this conversation
yeah it could be cool too if you had you
could do there's a whole bunch of
interesting stuff you could do you could
have seasons so you could have the first
collection of season one and then
another collection season two that's a
cool thing people are doing you can make
it into a dow so that the folks maybe
the folks who who have nfts get to go
into a private discord server you have
some events with them maybe you give
them some governance rights and deciding
which projects to
to fund and think of it as like then you
have this i don't know how many nf do
you have 10 000 that's just the number
people pick you have this army of not
only do you have funding but you have
evangelists and they're meaning and
they're
twittering and you know writing about it
they're building yeah they can even
build yeah they can build on top of it
they encode on top of it this is
fundamentally what nft's enable or
digital property rights enable our old
model was go back to marx and the theory
of labor there which is that capitalists
own the means of production labor has to
seize the means of production and then
now what someone still has to run the
factory so okay we hand them to the
state now the state runs the factories
and you get these horrible cars coming
out of the soviet union well that didn't
work so what makes sense is for the
workers to own the means of production
of the users the means of production in
proportion to how much value they're
providing essentially they should all be
shareholders and they should all be
shareholders in an open system with no
corporate overlord and no state overlord
in proportion to the value they're
providing into the system and if they
don't like the current distribution the
current system like bitcoin they can go
create their own and all the way down to
the board ape yacht club so there's just
this huge opportunity now to make every
person a worker an investor a
shareholder an evangelist an owner a
creator a designer we can fold it all
into one and that's really what web
three is enabling with tokens at the
core and it would be a mistake to just
think of this as securities law investor
protection and derivatives i get that's
where it started because you have to
create money internet native money first
before any of this is possible but now
that we have internet native money we
can start creating true internet native
corporations internet native collectives
internet native projects internet native
platforms that are owned by the users
and nipping it in the butt at this point
would be a huge mistake because all we
would have done is we've created the
internet native money but we would not
have allowed it to have all of its use
cases we would not not have allowed it
to create the new internet that we need
to live in here here
chris i'm gonna ask a very important
question i said i'd like you to speak
candidly
what's the story with the trident gum
oh my god katie told you this huh
well you know all the bad habits to have
at this point i have one which is like
yeah i chew gum non-stop and i don't
know
for whatever reason it seems to annoy
some people but i was doing this
dao called friends with benefits that we
invested in and i did a um kind of a
community talk
as part of kind of our investment
process and was chewing gum the whole
time and it actually became kind of a
meme
after that
so
now is ten packs a day hyperbole or is
are we talking about this serious that
might be true that might be
i have like a
uh
subscriptions of boxes of trinomials
i think at this point
you know i smoked a long time ago so
that's why it was a long time ago but i
just after that i just always chewed gum
i think it's just like a nervous habit
or something on the hierarchy of vices
yeah i feel like i'm hierarchy
i don't know how you feel about maybe
they'll discover that the trident gum
kills you or something i hope not i
think you're okay on the treadmill i
want to ask just a couple of unrelated
questions they could be related answers
but unrelated questions and then we're
going to come back around and each of
you guys if you want to add any closing
comments we can add those and if not
that's that's totally fine as well
i don't know if you gift books you
probably gift or recommend books when
you think of most books you have gifted
or recommended the most to others do any
come to mind
as i mentioned i really like history and
i particularly like the era of the
victorian industrial age of 1850 to 1920
or something it's an amazing period
where you i kind of think of it as it
appeared we had like 100 elon musks so
you had westinghouse and edison and ford
and the wright brothers and just bell
just goes on and on right and you had
that period where
just the number of incredible inventions
during that period in that 50-year
period i mean the airplane the car the
phonograph the light bulb for god's sake
this amazing book called empires of
light it's the battle between
westinghouse and edison really it's
fascinating it's they it was enterprise
sales they invented the light bulb
westinghouse says uh ac edison sdc
and they just went like town to town
selling them and like use my system and
there was this awesome moment at the end
that kind of coup de gras was
westinghouse built the key benefit of ac
is it goes farther without losing power
he built this giant plant up with
niagara falls and then turned the lights
on in buffalo and it was like this magic
act
also they all like
borrowed tons of money and the other
thing that's cool about them is they're
all engineers it reminds me a lot they
all started off in the telegraph
business which at the time was sort of
the internet of that era so that was
cool there's another book sorry i have
crypto on my brain i can't help it
there's a book i really like called the
company a short history of the llc
this is a fascinating book the name is
the company or the company yeah and i
can follow up the link but um it but
it's a history of limited liability
corporation which is a very very
controversial concept to have limited
liability because the thought before
this is around 1830 when it started to
develop was that you basically before
that you had to have a act of parliament
in the uk
to get limited liability because it was
considered this very dangerous thing why
shouldn't you be fully liable if you
start a railroad company and somebody
dies you should go to jail and so what
that meant when you before the llc
was that
if you were going to
invest
as an investor you could lose more than
your money and so as a result you only
had partnerships of like 10 and fewer
people basically families because who
are you going to trust
if you have unlimited liability it's
like your brother and your so-and-so but
like nobody else
and then what happened is in the 1830s
or so there was this railroad boom in
the uk first i believe and then in the
us
and they needed jaggery capital so
anytime two towns would link up a
railroad their economies would like 5x
so every town basically had this giant
line of people at parliament saying hey
can we get limited liability because we
can't afford to build that railroad but
we know it'll pay off but we need to be
able to go out to third parties and get
that capital and so that eventually was
very controversial and it took 30 years
or something but finally that became
that was like the business model of
delaware by the way which is genius they
were like hey we'll be the place you go
finally it became understood this was a
very important innovation i would argue
that actually a lot of the victorian
industrial stuff i was just talking
about came from actually the invention
of the llc and i bring that up because i
think it's very analogous to i kind of
see the historical progression of
partnerships for 10 people
10 people could accrue value in a llc
world a million people can accrue value
and
in a token world a billion people can't
it's this natural kind of progression
and it also shows you that tech is not
just always tech tech is sometimes
social and legal structures like the llc
so i thought it's a very short book
i think the part i'm discussing might
only been two chapters of it or
something but i thought fascinating i
don't think we normally think of these
kinds of legal innovations as kind of a
quote tech breakthrough
so i don't think there's a lot of
obviously there's a lot of great books i
love books these just happen to come to
mind those are two great examples i'm
gonna i'm gonna pick up both of those
naval do you have any additional
comments you would like to to add
questions
complaints
anything at all
when tim ferriss nft dropped
yeah i'm planning on it this is not idle
chat i'm extremely immersed and
i am
really
excited
in a way that i haven't been excited
about a project in a very long time and
just to
again make it plain i mean who knows
maybe at some point i'll do something
for profit but as it stands right now i
am excited to
pilot a project where 100 of the
proceeds
go to
some type of
research or project vis-a-vis probably
this
501c3 foundation this private foundation
that i have which has already done a lot
of work has a great track record over
the last few years so i would say next
six months would be
my goal so let's call it
depending on when this comes out but
first two quarters of 2022
would be my guess
great i would add on to what chris was
saying about you know going from 10
owners to
thousands of owners to millions of
owners to a billion owners i think
there's finally an answer for
how can communities participate in web3
and crypto before this you know when
people ask like how do i participate in
crypto those names for individuals which
is hey you can bet on
sound money digital gold that's bitcoin
and then if you were a company you could
say hey you can build something on top
of ethereum you can build decentralized
finance you can build applications on
this computer this touring complete
blockchain that is running computers
running on the blockchain
and now for the first time a community
can show up and you can have an answer
for the community you can say okay if
you have a passionate group of believers
you can spread ownership amongst them
you can spread governance amongst them
you can build a dao you can issue nfts
you can have an online gaming community
you can have a conversational community
you can have a real world community that
maps to each other with nfts you can
even have digital bake sales who knows
it's innovating like crazy but for the
first time we're seeing daos which are
these distributed autonomous
organizations take off in web 3 and daos
are sort of these
they're not quite corporations they're
not quite communities they're kind of
they're not quite networks or platforms
they're like their own new thing
that are a mixture of all of the above
and i think a couple of years from now
we're going to see a lot of thriving
communities on the internet that are now
linked together economically
intrinsically and are doing not just not
just making money but also governance
like who gets to make which decision who
gets credit for the decision who gets to
join the company who gets to leave the
company let's join the community lead
the community nfts are so many things
it's almost i love the chris webpage
analogy i want to give you full credit
for that i hadn't heard that until now
so sorry i haven't been listening to
another podcast but i love it because
web pages are so programmable it can be
anything the same with nft is so
programmable so it's kind of almost
silly to sit around talking about what
you can do with nfts you can do anything
with nfts that you can do with a web
page but on top of it
you can have scarcity and ownership and
allocation and rights associated with it
this is really big yeah i want to add
something
because you just reminded me also thank
you for that
and that is
i think dows have tremendous value
to government in a number of different
ways
whether to and this could be value to
different
scales of government
all the way up to the federal level
could apply to international
organizations could apply to the
military and that is
and i recommend to everyone if they can
find interviews with a lawyer named
aaron wright
who has been intimately involved with
the formation of many of the most famous
dows
daos offer the
ability to test different
types of governance and decision making
so
that could be rough consensus it could
be true consensus it could be any
permutation just about that you can
imagine
you can test
quickly and
this offers i think
incredibly valuable opportunities
to test in the micro via dows and to
observe what many dows are doing
to study what they're doing
not just for the implementation that you
see in the dao's but for taking
the best of breed options that emerge
and then applying them in other places i
think there's just tremendous value
there that was another moment kind of a
flash boil moment for me when i was
listening to aaron and i thought holy
[ __ ] this actually
is a huge deal and i'm sure i'm drinking
the kool-aid and missing certain things
but even if i
get half of it wrong i still think that
the implications are enormous
before we sign off can i add a
disclaimer for you here yes please
well we mentioned lots of nft projects
and companies this is not a
recommendation to go and buy any of them
and i think you have to be very careful
because most of these will be like 1999
you know dot bom so to speak where in
the first generation if you'd bet
everything on the flickers and the
delicious of the world you wouldn't have
done as well as if you just waited for
the netflix and the pinterest so it's
not too late the good news about nfts
being fashion and creative means it's
always new it's always bubbling up i've
talked to a lot of top nft collectors
now because i completely missed the boat
and i now realized why i missed the boat
because like psychopaths they were
buying it for the art value they
genuinely liked the art and they wanted
to be patrons of the arts and they
wanted to support the artists and it
didn't have anything to do with making
money it's just that then later the rest
of the group or small another larger
group came along and recognized that
there was some value to the art and to
the provenance of it so the good news
here i think with nfts is that now
everybody will get to play in web3
everybody will get to play in crypto
you're gonna have a lot of creators
making money you'll have a lot of fans
making money you'll have fans expressing
their devotion and their interest which
is really where it comes from because
underneath even though some of these art
projects will turn into larger
franchises that will launch movies and
games and books and all that stuff many
won't and many will just be a patronage
link between the person who's collecting
or buying and the artist and that's
great i want to be able to support an
artist without having to buy a sneaker
in the way that they market it i should
just be able to support them directly i
want to be able to support a fitness
expert online without having to buy some
bs vitamin that they have to stamp their
name on to some supplement company that
they have to start i want to be able to
support a singer or musician without
having to just pay spotify 10 bucks a
month and hoping it finds its magic
weight of them i want to be able to
support somebody on twitter instead of
just retweeting and liking all the time
so
we're establishing direct linkages
economic linkages and governance
linkages between communities of fans and
artists and i think that's wonderful so
if you want to go buy nfts buy the stuff
you like because at the end of the day
what you're probably going to end up
with is a cool jpeg
i
second that definitely only yeah i would
only recommend buying things that you
want to keep and not things you think
will go up in value because that's
dangerous
yeah it is dangerous and by this time
people will have also heard a disclaimer
at the beginning of the show so pay
attention to the disclaimer people the
the flicker delicious
analogy is a very apt one
it is
still really early
just because you missed the opportunity
to buy
jpegs for a dollar that are now worth
a million dollars and there are examples
of this
a it doesn't mean that you missed
all the boats maybe you missed one boat
secondly it doesn't mean all of those
nfts are going to maintain or appreciate
so
be patient i really feel like with the
amount of exploration and
experimentation that is happening right
now
and i mean chris you tell me if i'm
completely
delusional here but
i really feel like
even though there is an impulse to rush
and there's an impulse to be in discords
24 hours a day and on crypto or nft
twitter 24 hours a day ultimately you
run out of hours and i do feel like
there is a place
for watching for learning for getting
educated for kicking the tires in ways
that are low risk or no risk
and
looking for fat pitches
whether that is
as a user or a fan looking for a real
fit with a creator or an artist or an
entrepreneur
who you love personally or whose work
you love or whose project you love or
looking for investments i feel like it
is a huge mistake to just
impulsively
from the driver of fomo dump a ton of
money
in hoping that you win the next willy
wonka golden ticket because uh
ultimately i think that is at least for
me is too high risk i think another lens
to look at in the teas through is
you go to the museum and you see a roman
statue okay there's sort of two ways you
could interpret that one is the piece of
stone and that's sort of just a jpeg the
other i think the correct way the more
sophisticated way is to see it as a
community artifact it has meaning
and value that statue as part of that
community of ancient rome and i think
the same thing's true with nfts nfts are
artifacts of networks so like you have
your own community and the nfts you're
creating will be artifacts for that
community and they derive value to the
extent that they kind of reinforce that
community's values
and norms and language and memes
that's what crypto punk's really you're
owning a piece of this community that
has importance in the history of the
internet and history of crypto if you
take it out of that that's when you get
to just a jpeg right click and save
thing i used to do this with you know i
go to the metropolitan museum of art oh
look that's a sword if you dismiss it
like that sure but if you want to go and
like dig in and so i think the same
thing for i would say for you tim i
would encourage you when you think about
your nfts to sort of think of it in that
way these are artifacts these are
artifacts of the community and by buying
one you're sort of buying both you're
supporting your cause but you're also
kind of buying into that community yeah
by the way the other interesting thing
one reason i think this is sort of so
powerful is that we've spent the last 30
years building communities on the
internet we didn't have a good way to
for them to accrue value but the killer
app of the internet is networks we've
got a million networks built on this
thing now discords and reddits and
twitter followings it's all built out
and now we're dropping in this way to
have now these community artifacts and
things with value and i think it's very
important to think of it in that context
and not what i think the mistake some
people are making now and this is
they're thinking it more transactionally
it's a cash grab that's the wrong way
and that will backfire you need to do it
in the way that the community really
aligns with the values of the community
yeah definitely by the way when you buy
these suits into balls point buy things
in communities you value and expect them
to be illiquid for a very long time if
you buy a crypto bunk or a board ape or
something else it's because you want to
be part of that community that should be
the motivation yeah everybody gets to be
a patron of the arts and a patron of the
sciences that's the way i think about
this and i'll also say if you're just a
aggressive capitalist and you're like i
don't give a [ __ ] about being a patron
nonetheless i think it is a very
dangerous game to think that you can out
trade
the rest of the universe and try to hold
and flip things and hold and flip things
for short periods of time or within
short periods of time so that is just to
say
naval you've famously said something
along the lines or written i guess i
think you said it first on the podcast
maybe maybe it was on twitter who the
hell knows if you wouldn't work with
someone for a lifetime don't work with
them for five minutes am i getting that
right something like that what is it
yeah it was literally my first
philosophical tweet where i was just
thinking out loud note to self yep and
it was if you can't see yourself working
with someone for life don't work with
them for a day there you go and it was a
lesson to me i was trying to telling
myself hey don't keep falling into that
trap there are no short term
relationships so for me looking at nfts
the way i've looked at them is if i
wouldn't hold this for it doesn't have
to be for life but like if i wouldn't
hold this for five years
don't hold it for five days don't buy it
in the first place if you're not ready
to do that because there are going to be
a lot of ups and downs and as uh
punk6529 said to me once he said uh and
i'm sure he's written this somewhere but
he said you know nfts make crypto look
like treasury bonds with respect to
volatility they are all over the place i
think that was mine maybe it was six
five two oh well he's maybe he told me
but maybe you said it okay you just
never know where it starts and i managed
to articulate a little better where i
think crypto is to venture as venture is
to value in other words investing in
crypto is to investing in venture
capital what doing venture capitalist
and doing value investing like warren
buffett does it's crazy yeah standard
deviation squared right everything is
the variance squared everything goes up
and down volatility you're going to make
10x 0x you're going to lose it all
you're going to get hacked the
blockchain is going to get i mean
there's so many ways to go wrong you'll
lose your keys boating accident whatever
there's a thousand ways to go wrong in
this space
so it's not for the faint of heart yeah
it's really not and it's true also in
the embryonic stages
and the wild west days of any of the
technological revolutions that we've
discussed the room hasn't been
childproofed yet no not at all and
that's okay but to chris's point yeah to
chris's point there the best teams are
not working on it they're figuring out
how to take it mainstream how to take
custody mainstream how to take
purchasing mainstream the gaming guys if
they can and gals if they can't figure
this out nobody can but i think they'll
figure it out i wanted to add one more
recommendation and that is well there
are two things we didn't have a chance
to get into which is totally fine
because there are a million
different directions you can go with
this stuff but one is
generative art
and art not necessarily referring only
to
graphic representational art but
generative art i recommend people check
out some of the writing by tyler hobbs
who is the
incredible artist
really nice guy creator of something
called the fidenzas which are incredible
and also incredibly popular
he's written many people have now
written about generated art but one
aspect of that that i think is
unique that will become more and more
compelling in different ways is the
ability for
the
purchaser of the art to become an
element
in the creation of the art so when you
purchase a piece of art you interact
with you guys are technical correct me
if i'm getting this wrong but
code that algorithm of some type and
your say transaction id i'm not sure if
there's a better term for that
becomes a factor in determining the
output of that code
and so you are by virtue of purchasing
something at a specific time
with a specific wallet
changing the output and creating a
one-of-a-kind piece of artwork that you
had a hand in helping create by being a
participant is that a fair description
anybody want to modify that yeah no
that's right that's right i think
there's a lot of i think that's one of
the cool things here is when you create
a better business model for art let's
say or for music step one will be you
take the existing artists and they get
more money step two is you're going to
incentivize a whole new generation to go
do these cool things with a generative
art now you have a way to make money on
it and so there's just going to be all
these smart people attracted to creative
things which i think is a great thing i
think we were just dramatically
underpaying creative people in my view
and we've now figured out a way to pay
them properly and that's going to lead
to a huge new wave of creative
activities
not just technology and not just paying
existing musicians maybe we enter a
world where there's instead of eight
million musicians on spotify there's a
billion
maybe there's a billion musicians
there's a billion artists
there's a millions of generative artists
i think this is the right kind of
evolution of the internet this should be
a golden period for creative people
there are eight billion people and six
billion or whatever internet connected
and you only need a thousand to make a
living this should be the greatest time
in history for creative people and i
think we might have finally figured it
out
going back to your hill climbing analogy
there should be eight billion different
careers yeah and each person should have
their own hill and some will be
mountains and some will be mole hills
but at least everyone gets their own
hill like take music how much do you
love music the supply is there the
demand is there we just don't have the
right model in between it's not like
people don't people are crazy about
music they love music
and there's plenty of people with money
who love music so why are musicians why
do we assume that the internet has to
make them destitute it's a very
defeatist attitude i think
it should be a golden period the
generative art stuff is cool i'm not an
expert on it but i just think it's so
cool that now like there's a business
model for generative art that is awesome
and like the kids that get excited by
that and go and i'm gonna be a
generative artist
that might be a new thing 10 years from
now i think it's definitely it's it's
going to be a thing in the very near
future from what i've seen art blocks is
worth checking out people should check
out art blocks
and i think it's
as you kind of both alluded to
it's going to expand the pie right so
naval you're intimately familiar with
this
when uber went
uber went out as a possible investment
on angel list how many rejections did
they get how many people declined
a couple of hundred yeah right and one
of the assumptions underpinning a lot of
those rejections
was
well how big is the total addressable
market for black sedans and then we're
going to look at a percentage of that
and what they didn't factor in was the
possibility that it would dramatically
multiply over and over again
the actual pool
of not just riders but drivers so it
completely flipped the paradigm on its
head
similarly
we might be inclined to say how many
professional musicians are there now
what percentage might be able to use
this and that's the wrong way of looking
at it when suddenly it is proven that it
is viable
to create a financially secure future by
creating whatever that means
it opens the floodgates right it opens
the possibilities and i think that the
early
even the generative art has been around
in one form or another for decades but
the experimentation now is just the tip
of the iceberg so it's very much kind of
model t so i'm very excited to see
what's coming in the next i mean the
time dilation with this stuff is bizarre
i feel like i've watched four years of
experimentation in the last
four months it's really pretty wild the
other thing to add to what you're saying
is we're probably in this schemorphic
period right now i don't know what the
native generative art looks like it's
probably yeah too advanced for my
artistic sense or something but
just timing wise almost always will look
back and say this is a skeuomorphic
period they aren't leaning into the
software code enough the stuff you
mentioned is like a nice kind of coding
thing but i bet you this is arbitrary
code i mean you can have we have one
company manifold which is trying to
create sort of let smart contracts nfts
be like an app store and you have
different software you can plug and play
onto just like the app store
one of my favorite things to do is look
at old computer ads
it's funny because like in the 80s all
the computer ads had this couple at the
table doing recipes
steve jobs as much of a genius as he was
like greatest genius of all time he
invents the computer and that's the
iphone and the best idea he had for what
to do with the computer in 1983 was a
couple organizing their kitchen recipes
so what i'm saying of course is he's a
genius but it's just really hard to know
so the first thing you do is i guess
they had like a filing system whatever
but then what happens right this army of
people come
and they invent the word processor and
the spreadsheet the spreadsheet was a
random guy in boston who just came up
with the idea of a spreadsheet and
desktop publishing and video games and
just this whole wave after wave of cool
stuff which even the inventor i'm just
trying to make a point of how hard it is
and so i think we're probably in the
kitchen recipe period of nfts which is
awesome because there's going to be so
much more cool stuff yeah i don't even
know how you got the recipes back then
they didn't have the internet got it
that's a male a tape
a giant tape with males
mobile phones the same thing remember
mobile phones there's always like stock
and weather they always talked about
stocks and weather right that was it
yeah it turns out it's it's tick tock
it's teenage dance videos on tick tock
tailing a car ephemeral messaging no one
knew it's so hard to know right so
anyways
i think we're we're in the the kitchen
recipe period
and we haven't even talked about we
don't need to go deeply into this but i
would imagine there's some percentage of
the
list ownership right now are like yeah i
still don't get it right we're talking
about jpegs and i've yeah okay somebody
i somebody on the internet said like
yeah you can take a photograph of the
mona lisa but is it really the same as
the mona lisa and like i don't really
get it
but there i would imagine are going to
be
all sorts of tie-ins and possibilities
and uses for nfts that tie into the
physical world so we didn't even get
into that as an example okay today you
buy a sneaker right and now maybe that
sneaker was sponsored by kanye or jay-z
or whatever and now there's variations
in sneaker well in the future maybe
you'll buy a unique sneaker and then
you'll get the nft for that sneaker and
then you'll have the unique copyright to
the digital representation of that
sneaker if somebody wants to use that
sneaker in a marketing campaign if if
nike comes along and says hey want to
feature that sneaker then maybe you get
royalties right these are just very
simple little examples but it's
essentially a social contract or even a
written contract that you have with the
person that sold you the nft that can be
used to imbue value in all kinds of ways
so it's an nft is not really
an object a digital object it is a
pointer it is a channel it's a link a
communication between you the creator
and the community and any kind of value
can be funneled down that it can be
accessed into things it can be
recognition and reputation it can be
royalties it can be copyrights it can be
remixed rights or it could just be
you're just sending them money because
you want to support them so it's
completely programmable we just don't
know
so for example people talk about
ticketing with nfts and what they mean
is like going to an existing event with
tickets like a sports game or music show
right but actually that's spemorphic i
think the native version of ticketing is
you have a tim ferriss nft and now i get
to
or let's say i whatever some nike nft
and i get a certain seat at this
restaurant why do wealthy people invest
in restaurants they don't invest
because they want to invest in
restaurants and get a good table like
why not just skip the whole investing
part and just have an nft have a bunch
of nfts i guarantee you the next six
months we're going to see like
conventions and other kinds of things of
nft board apes and crypto punks and and
by the way if you're a business and you
want to find some really good customers
people that own crypto punks are
probably really good customers i think
you can see a world where instead of
doing the web 2 companies surveilling
you and trying to figure out your
interests you're just declaring your
interest through nfts and so it's done
in an opt-in way that's pro user the
user has the power but that's a very
valuable thing that people will use for
incentives and
various other things i mean if you have
a crypto punk that says a lot about you
exactly if you have a crypto punk and
you're tweeting then i know that you're
an og into nfts and you probably know
what you're talking about and you've got
serious money at stake behind what
you're saying
chris i thought it might be interesting
for folks i love how i asked my last
question 40 minutes ago so we'll wrap up
in a minute but
friends with benefits best name of all
time side note but you didn't really
explain friends with benefits and i
think it's a curious example
in permutation of what we're talking
about could you describe friends with
benefits please
sure so in just a few contexts i
not the general term the company i don't
know
very strongly that venture capital we
need to be constantly taking risks and
so one of the things we started doing
like six months ago we started pretty
invested heavily investing in this area
called daos you know this is a new type
of investment where there aren't there
really isn't like even in many cases
like a legal entity and we're buying
tokens and other kinds of things and you
know there's a lot of questions but it's
it's early but we want to be there on
the frontier and i think this is the
frontier so friends of benefits it's a
dao which means it's a think of if
someone said a dao think of a dao as a
internet community with a balance sheet
okay so it's an internet community but
they also have resources and can do
stuff in the particular case fwb is a
bunch of web3 product developers so it's
a couple thousand people who are really
high-end high-quality product developers
and they're spinning out cools they have
events i we hadn't we hosted an event in
new york with them
it's like someone on our team said oh my
god this new wave of crypto is like 100x
cooler
than all of us like we're like it's very
different than 2017 and 16 you know a
bunch of computer nerds talking about
protocols this is the coolest people
from williamsburg but which is great but
they they're really it's great they're
great community they're designers
they're developers they don't they're
not sort of hard like they really got
into this stuff kind of more recently
which is good because they really got i
think the cultural aspects got them
excited the nft stuff more than you know
to them like money the money stuff
before was kind of a turn off
and it's just like a cool i don't know
it's like it's university of utah
it's the homebrew computer club the
homebrew computer club of 2021 is
probably a dow
and we want to join a bunch of them and
just and just learn from these people
who are just more in the they're smart
and they're in the trends and this is
how we learn right i would also suggest
people check out aaron wright there are
other people certainly speaking great
but there are different
almost i suppose you consider the
categories of taos right they're
acquisition daos
one of the better known beings say
flamingo very successful incredible
collection of nft artwork and assets
so there are different purposes and
that's just going to multiply i would
imagine
over time now quick question on fwb did
they decide oh [ __ ] we can't call
ourselves with benefits long term and
they like went from kentucky fried
chicken to kfc kind of not to be
confused with kyc i don't know if
they've actually tried to rebrand i just
kind of everyone laughs whenever we say
the name so i just
stick to your guns friends with benefits
i love it i i it'll go far stick with it
all right on that note any final
comments guys of course you guys can be
found on the internet nevall at naval
navy al on twitter chris c dixon
c dixon.org also
a16z
and i'll include some additional links
in the show notes as well as the 30 page
or so booklet that you mentioned chris
at team dot blog dixon
anything else you guys would like to
to add as closing comments yes yes some
career advice for you tim which is uh
when i first learned about crypto i
didn't actually get into it because i
was busy with angelus i wrote a few
tweets i wrote a few position pieces but
i really didn't wake up into it until
much later when i you know a lot of the
gains were gone and i wasn't fully
joking when i said that this may turn
into a conversion to a crypto podcast so
you know don't wait too long hill
climbing man you might be on the wrong
hill is all i'm saying
oh man the blind leading the blind well
i may need to invite you to co-host
naval be careful we'll see how it works
well thanks guys this was a lot of fun
and appreciate you carving out the time
so to be continued i'm sure we'll
continue chatting offline and to
everybody listening you can find all the
resources links to everything books
projects companies et cetera in the show
notes as per usual in this case tim dot
blog slash dixon d-i-x-o-n and until
next time
be safe out there don't take unnecessary
risks don't play with any money you
can't afford to lose none of this is
investment advice just for informational
purposes only like this fine podcast
another reason i like to keep my topics
broad naval ravicon all right everybody
thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog
friday drop in your email and you'll get
the very next one
thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by tonal
imagine having an entire gym's worth of
equipment in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv something that could fit
potentially even in a closet
fits in my closet by eliminating
traditional weights total can deliver
200 pounds of resistance with a sleek
design that can fit nearly anywhere it's
like having an entire gym and personal
trainer right in your home tonal's
patented digital weight system senses
your strength and adjusts the weight
automatically in real time so you can
get the most out of every workout a
number of friends including competitive
athletes who have doubled their strength
in a short order in a lot of exercises
and part of the reason that's possible
is it uses a revolutionary system of
dynamic resistance powered by electric
motors for strength you can feel you can
also do things like eccentrics
over time tonal learns from your body
and automatically increases the weight
exactly when you can handle it tonal
also uses 17 sensors to provide
real-time feedback on your form and
technique allowing you to get the most
effective workout every time it's a
strength training machine with
adjustable arms that provides more than
170 exercises for a full body workout
and that can include squats deadlifts
bench presses overhead pulls bicep curls
and more so check it out try tonal the
smartest home gym for 30 days in your
home total is so confident that you'll
love it they offer a full money back
guarantee you can now get total from 63
dollars per month at a zero percent
interest over 48 months
visit
www.tonal that's t-o-n-a-l dot com and
for a limited time get 100 off when you
use promo code tim 100 at checkout
that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim 100 tim100
tonal be your strongest this episode is
brought to you by theragun i have two
theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day muscle pain and
muscle tension are real things that's
why i use the theragun i use it at night
i use it after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest muscle tension so for
instance at night i might use it on the
bottom of my feet it's helped with my
plantar fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact as massage
reinvented on some level helps with
performance helps with recovery helps
with just getting your back to feel
better before bed after you've been
sitting for way too many hours i love
this
and the all new gen 4 theragun has a
proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet it's easy to use and
about as quiet as an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing and you really
have to feel the theragun's signature
power amplitude and effectiveness to
believe it it's one of my favorite
gadgets in my house at this point so i
encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen four theragon with an oled
screen that's oled for those wondering
that's organic light emitting diode
screen personalized theragon app and an
incredible combination of quiet and
power and the gen 4th era guns start at
just 199 i said i have two i have the
prime and i also have the pro which is
like the super cadillac version my
girlfriend loves these soft attachments
on that so try theragun for 30 days
starting at only 199
go to therabody.com
tim right now and get your gen 4
theragun today one more time that's
therabody.com tim
t-h-e-r-a-b-o-d-y dot com slash
[Applause]
you